Hello everybody!
Hello, hello.
I'm waiting for like the gamer subs to kick in right now.
I'm so tired.
I'm so fucking tired.
Regular people have done a five.
I have 24-7 work life.
I woke up early today, so yes, I was on an adventure today.
By adventure, I went to the hair salon.
So today, I woke up early today because I went to bed early.
And by early, I meant I went to bed at like 1 in the morning.
So I was like, so obviously I woke up at around... well, technically I didn't wake up out of my own free will.
I woke up because dad was like...
Dad, okay, so like, you know, I was like, like I opened my eyes and then Doki and Badoge, he sleeps with me.
So like he was, you know, underneath the covers.
But he could feel that I was awake.
He felt the moment.
So he was like, oh, you're awake, huh?
Oh, you know what that means?
It's feeding time!
So he like jumped down from the bed.
I was like...
AHHHHHH!
I was like, please...
He was like, FOOD TIME!
FEED ME!
I was like, looked at my phone, I was like, please, it's 9 in the morning.
I was like, please, you know, you know it's not eating time, but come on.
So like, I tried to like ignore him because, um, because it's not good because then it re-reinforces that behavior.
Because if you like acknowledge him, acknowledge the dog when he's barking, then he'll be like, oh, I see every time I bark, every time I bark, you will feed me.
So I let him bark for like, five... I don't even know at this point, I don't know how long he was barking.
I just, I was just like, I was just like, this is my life, this is my life.
I was like, he was like, AHHHH!
FEED ME!
And I'm just in my bed staring at the ceiling, and I'm like, I'm just staring at the ceiling, I was like, this will stop, this will stop.
So, um, so, um, I like let him have his, you know, have his time for like five, I don't know how long, but then eventually he stopped.
I waited a little bit, he like walked out of the room, came back, looked at me, and then I like, and then I got up.
I got up, and then I fed him, and then I went back to bed, but I couldn't fall asleep, I couldn't fall asleep.
So I was like, alright, time to get some work done, um, so, you know, I clocked in my hours, because I was like, well, it's gonna be a while until it's my stream time.
And I realized, you know, since I'm up really early, I was like, you know, I haven't, you know, I haven't done anything with my hair in a long ass time.
So like, I did got it cut a while ago, like three months ago, I think, like, but it was just like a typical cut, and then like lighten, uh, and also like lighten it.
So like, because it was getting too long, and I really don't like it when my hair is way too long, because then I hate doing hair maintenance when it's a really long hair.
Because like, you know, showering is a little, is a bitch when you have long hair, and um, and just like maintain, like, you know, maintaining it and everything, because I have a really thick set of hair.
So I was just like, ah, fuck it, like, you know what, and also like, this is like, people were like, wait, you have like white hair?
Okay, so, for those who don't know, um, for those who don't know, uh, I have a genetic defect where, don't say that.
Doki, that's... why do you call it that?
So, I have a genetic defect since I was really young, since I was like, I think like four or five, um, where I occasionally get like white hair.
Um, so like, I will have like bits of strands of white hair, and then I, you know, um, I, this seems to be blonde hair, but like, um, I have, you know, black hair.
Uh, sometimes.
My other skin suit has black hair.
Immersion.
Anyway, um, so, it's very noticeable, especially when you're fucking four.
So, um, so, um, basically, um, um, so, you know, I would be like, he was like, you know, teachers would be like, wow, you have white hair.
Like, you know, teachers would judge you and shit, because they're like, why the fuck does this child have white hair?
And I wouldn't notice it, really, because I can't see my own head.
So, like, I didn't, I was like, yeah, why do I have white hair?
I was like, I'm a child.
I'm like, I'm a child.
And then, like, you know, my Asian relatives, you know, you know, Asian relatives, they love the gossip and everything and judge you, but try to make it positive, but it's like passive-aggressive judging, you know?
Like, no, what's it called?
Like, fake optimistic judge.
Like, fake optis- uh, uh, uh, um, uh, uh, what is it called?
Optimism?
What is it?
When they're trying to, when they're trying to, they're judging you, but they make it as if, like, it's positive, but you know it's not.
Like,
like, uh, optimistic, uh, fake comp- like, what's it called?
Backhanded compliments?
Uh, toxic positivity?
I don't know, uh, but, like, you know, uh, guys, like, sorry, I, I, like, slurred my words.
I stumbled.
I meant optim- optimism.
I didn't mean the other.
I didn't mean autism.
I meant opt- guys, please, English is my first language.
Anyway, um, um, anyway, so, you know, like, Asian relatives, they say something, and they're trying to, like, pretend it's positive, but you know it's not.
So, um, they were, you know, they would judge me, and I was, like, you know, I was super young.
I was, like, four to, like, ten years old, and even, like, even till, like, my teenage years, and they would be, like, wow, why do you keep having- why do you have gray hair, and white hair, and everything?
So, I've been dying my hair since I was four.
So, my mom would always take me to hair salons since I was four to, like, dye my hair so I don't get judged by my Asian relatives, because it's all about, like, the image.
Like, you know, I didn't give a fuck.
I was four, but, you know, like, you know, it's all about upholding that image that I'm not a freak.
So, um, so, um, yeah, um, anyway, um, um, um, so, basically, uh, the reason- and then, like, I, you know, I was confused.
I was, like, why do I have white hair?
Like, I'm just, like, why do I have white hair?
Why doesn't all the other kids have white hair?
I thought you'd get white hair when you're old.
And so, um, so, um, you know, like, what my parents would tell me, you know, like, lie to you.
You know, your parents don't want to tell you the real reason, so they lie to you.
So the lie they told me when I was growing up, they're like, oh, it's because you're so smart, because you're always thinking, and because you're always thinking, you know, you're you grow white hair because you're always thinking.
And I was like, that makes sense.
Like, I was like, wow, I'm so smart.
That makes sense.
Yeah, that's why I got white hair.
I'm always thinking.
There's so much in my mind.
And later on, I found out, um, I found out it's because, um, what is it called?
Is it melanin?
I, oh my gosh, hair produce color.
What is it called?
Um, yeah, melanin.
So I don't have enough pigment colors to produce the colors needed to, to, you know, to keep up with the colors.
So, uh, I don't have enough melanin for it.
That's why I have white hair.
So, you know, I've been dying my, like, not, not, you know, not like out of choice.
Like my parents would just take me to the hair salon.
Like, I don't really care that much to be honest.
Uh, so, uh, I just don't have enough melanin to, yeah, I just, I ran out of ink, basically.
If you want to talk, speaking of ink, I need you guys to help me buy a printer.
I need to order a printer on Amazon.
So I have, like, after the stream, you're, after, like, Call of Duty, you guys are going to help me buy a printer, order a printer, because I don't know what printer you get.
Anyway, uh, and also a kettle.
Anyway, as I was saying, so, basically, I don't have enough ink to produce the color and that's why I get white hair.
So, I haven't dyed.
I've been so busy and there was no reason for me to dye my hair for a long time.
Um, and also, like, um, in the past, I've gone to, like, my mom's, uh, best friend and her husband's hair salon for, like, I think, like, for since I was four, but, like, I don't like them.
Because I, I just feel like, so, like, you know, for, I haven't dyed my hair.
Um, okay, there's, like, family drama regarding that.
Uh, there's, like, it's so, there's, I don't know, I just find them weird.
I, I find them, okay, so, TLDR, I'll give you guys a TL, I'll talk, I'll tell the story at another time, but TLDR, um, um, like, the best friend, um, you know, and her husband, they, they, they opened a hair salon together.
Um, so, they used to work together and everything and, uh, and they have, like, three kids together, um, and everything and they had, like, three houses together and, like, she, like, they were, like, award-winning hairstylists, so they've done, like,
Miss Canada pageants and everything, like, they've done, like, hairs for, like, really big people, like, celebrities and stuff, and then, um, and then, all of nowhere, she suddenly divorced him after, you know, having three kids and they bought a new house together and,
no, they're, like, house flippers.
They weren't, like, actually, they were house flippers, too, on top of, like, uh, doing hair stuff.
So, after the third kid, like, when the kid was, like, two to three years old, after the third kid, they divorced.
I think they have four kids, actually.
I don't know, three kids or four kids.
I, I lost track of all the children because there were so many.
Um, she, out of nowhere, suddenly divorced him because she was, like, I want to find, like, I, like, she's, like, you are not in my path, like, you are not part of, like, my journey and, you know, he's, like, in love with her and everything.
Even he was, like, what the fuck, like He was, like, oh, what the fuck happened?
And then, and then she became, like, incredibly spiritual and everything.
So she became incredibly spiritual and, like, does, like, and then she ended up, like, dating this other guy that was, like, oh my god, how do I explain?
I didn't like him either.
Like, I remember, like, because I had to get my, like, you know, I had to get my hair, like, my annual, like, my, not annual, but, like, you know, I get my hair dyed and stuff and cut and then, um, and then, so I had to, like, go to her house and stuff and then,
like, meet her boyfriend and then, like, and he was, like, how do I explain this?
He's a hippie.
Like, that's, like, the best way, the best, the best way to explain it.
So, like, you know, I don't like wearing shoes type deal and, like, um, um, vegetarian, I don't know if he was vegetarian, vegan.
I don't remember.
It was, it was a long time ago.
It was so, I don't know.
And then, like, um, and then, like, he would make the dog, like, he, like, I don't know, no offense to those who, like, cook for your dog, but, like, he would feed the dog human food, too.
So, like, he would, he cooked dinner for us and he cooked the same meal for the dog as well and then had, like, the dog eat at the table and, like, it's just, and he doesn't have a job.
So, like, it's just weird.
I...
It's just, it's just weird.
And then, um, so he's, like, living off of her and stuff and then, um, yeah, and then, um, I, it was, and I, I just felt weird getting my hair done at, like, her house at that point, like, not even a house, her, like, apartment.
I, it felt weird getting my hair done at her apartment.
And then she tried to make a documentary about hair and, like, try to ask, like, everybody she knew for money to fund this documentary about hair and I, it was, it's so weird.
I, that's why I was, like, oh my god, I can finally, like, decide where to get my own hair done.
I don't want to go to her or the husband anymore for, like, majority of my life.
Um, I basically got my hair done by them because, like, like, you know, like, it's, like, you know, friend, friend discount and stuff.
Yeah, so, that's her.
The husband, sorry, this ended up not being a TLDR.
There's so much more, though, to be honest.
The husband became bachelor crazy, as in he became a playboy.
I don't know, that's, that's the best I could describe it.
He became a fucking, he became a playboy.
Because he was like, he's like, I'll never find love again.
And then, like, and then, like, it got to the point where my dad hated hanging out with him because he would always try to hang out, ask my dad to hang out, and then he was like, I don't want to hang out with him, man.
It's so depressing, like.
Like, I remember, like, overhearing conversations between my parents because they're like, oh, yeah, like, hey, um, you know, she, her, the husband, like, and then, and then they would never call, they would call him, like, this, the, the, like, oh, my best friend's husband wants to hang out with you.
And then my dad would be like, I don't want to hang out with him, man.
It's so depressing, like, like, he just wants to do this, and I, it's just, I don't know.
Um, and I was just like, what the fuck?
Um, um, but anyway, so, yeah.
That's, like, I'm happy I don't have to get my hair done by, like, either of them anymore.
So, basically, I haven't got my hair done in a year, like, an actual, like, hair done type deal.
So, um, I went to the, I, I was like, I have time.
I'm gonna do, like, I was checking appointments and stuff, like, the nearest spot nearby, and they had an appointment at, like, 12 p.m., like, walk-in type deal.
Like, I don't know.
I scheduled appointments, like, anybody would do.
I don't really care, like, like, I don't really care that much.
At best, I just wanted to dye, I just wanted to correct the white hair and everything so that I don't have to worry too much about, you know, I, you know, I just want to be like, you know what, it's been a year plus, even more maybe, it's been a year plus,
oh my god, definitely more than a year, like, half a year, almost, like, two years since I got my hair done.
And I was like, oh yeah, lots of, you know, I, since I haven't, like, touched up my hair, I was like, all right, I'm gonna go, like, you know, cover up the white hair and white strands and stuff.
And, um, and so, like, I was like, 12 p.m., that's fine.
Like, it mostly, like, it says, like, it should be quick.
And I went in and the guy was like, um, the guy was like, oh, um, oh my god, your hair is too different.
Your hair, like, because, like, you know, I didn't keep it consistent, so, like, the bottom was, like, brownish and then the top was black.
And then, so, they were like, wow, like, you might need a full cover because it's inconsistent.
And I was like, what a full cover?
He's like, yeah, like, you gotta, we gotta do a full dye job because, like, this is, like, you can't just touch this up.
You have to, you know.
And then, like, I have full strands of white hair.
It's not, like, it's at the top.
It's, like, it grew and everything.
And then, so I was like, oh, okay, how much would that cost?
And then he was like, well, we have to do this and then we have to do that.
We gotta do scalp protection.
And he's like, you wanna, you wanna, like, use this different dye?
I don't even know what they're called because I was like, there's so much, there's, like, new things.
Like, and then, because, you know, usually when I was at the salon, I'd just be like, I don't care, just, like, and then, like, my mom would be like, she wants to do this, this, this.
And I'm like, oh, shit, now I have to decide all of this myself.
And then, and then they were like, yeah, like, we could do, use this type of dye, which is healthier for your scalp because it burns less and, like, it doesn't burn or, like, it's, like, it smells better and everything.
And I was just like, oh, okay.
It was $300.
It was a $300 salon trip.
I, I booked for, I booked for $100.
It was $300.
It was a $300.
Being a woman, fucking suck.
You guys would be like, no, no, no, this is what happens when you're a lady and you're trying to go to a salon.
This is what it's, no, trust me, like, it is what it's like when you're a woman going to a hair salon.
It's so fucking expensive.
It's actually, like, um, cause guys, it's just snip, snip, leave.
It's like, that's why people buy, like, like those box dyes.
I don't know how to use box dyes.
So that's why people, and it's not that healthy for your head too.
Um, so like when, cause like guys, it's easy.
We have to like, Oh my God.
I sat there for three hours.
I sat there for three hours getting my hair done.
And then also I had to get a little cut.
Cause I was like, I, you know, I didn't want to worry about cutting my hair another time.
I was like, I fucking, I'm already paying for expensive dye job.
So I might as well, I might as well fucking snip, snip my hair.
Wash, give me a massage too.
Like, you know, when you're at a nice salon, like it wasn't even like the best salon out there.
Like I literally was so close by.
And then they like massage your head.
I was like, pay $300, massage my head more.
He was like, do you want me to massage more?
I was like, yes.
I might as well.
That's the only free thing I get out of $300.
Keep massaging my head.
Like, uh, make this worth it.
Um, and he gave me free snacks.
It was really nice to be fair.
Cause they're like, oh, we got her.
We actually made her pay $300.
They're like, I can't believe we actually made her pay $300 for, for a hair salon trip.
Here's some free, here's some free $10 snacks.
I got like a tray of snacks too, to like keep me occupied and everything.
Um, so like, that was nice.
He was a nice guy.
He was like really nice stylist.
Cause he kept asking like, is everything okay?
Like, are you okay?
And everything.
And like, you know, mentally, no, I'm not.
But like here in the moment, I'm like, yeah, I guess.
I guess I'm okay.
Um, but yeah, that was my hair salon trip today.
Um, oh my gosh.
I wrote like an entire page of like things I want to talk about.
Also, I wasn't able to, my friend couldn't make it in the end because like they had last minute work to do that was given to them.
So like, I ended up not doing the Halloween event instead.
Uh, like I ended up not going, well I did go outside, but I didn't do the wanted to do originally because he couldn't make it.
Um, so like, uh, um, good thing.
Cause I did not buy an air mattress.
So I was gonna buy an air mattress and then like they messaged me like, oh, I have to cancel.
I was like, all right, don't have to buy an air mattress.
At least I did go outside.
I actually went to an Halloween farmer's market, um, on one of the days and, um, I have a problem.
I have a problem with bread.
Like, I don't know why I swear every time I see bread at a farmer's market, I can't help myself.
Like I just, I was just like, oh my, I bought a bag of bread.
I full of just random assortment of goods.
Like, I don't know what, I don't know.
There were so many stalls at the farmer's market selling bread.
I had to force myself to not buy at two of the bread stalls.
They were so cute.
Some of them were like shaped like things.
There was like, there was a cookie shaped like Pikachu.
I, I almost bought it.
I was like, oh my, that is so cute.
But like I haven't eaten a single one of those.
I only ate like, okay.
So like I haven't eaten a single one of the baked goods I bought.
It's just bad.
Cause like it's in the fridge right now, but it's just, I couldn't help it.
Like I have a problem.
Anyway, I was at one of the stalls at the farmer's market and like, this was so evil.
Like I didn't, I didn't mean to.
It was a very popular stall because I went there 30 minutes after it opened.
And then like almost everything was sold out already, which was crazy.
Cause I like, I didn't know, I've never seen this.
I don't go outside much.
Like now I do.
Tomorrow I have to go outside again because I have to go to the bank.
I'm freaking if I see that guy again at the bank.
Anyway, cause I need to make more art transfers.
Anyway, today, not today, um, the farmer's market.
Uh, so I was like, whoa, it must be really good.
So I was lining up and they had one loaf of bread left.
Like, you know, a loaf of bread.
And it was like, apparently it was like, um, a, um, a Japanese bakery.
So like it was made with like Japanese ingredients.
So they had one loaf of bread left.
It was almost all, everything was almost all sold out.
And I was like, I need that one loaf of bread.
And I, and then, and then I bought that one loaf of bread.
And then the grandma behind me, this old Asian grandma behind me was like, oh, do you not have any bread left?
They would try it.
I was paying for, I had other, I bought like another two other stuff with that loaf of bread.
And then the granny behind me was like, oh my, do you have any left?
Like you don't sell at my, your bakery that was near my place.
You don't sell these bread.
I wanted to have one of like, I've been wanting to buy these loafs of bread for so long.
Cause your bakery that's near my place doesn't sell it or it's always sold out.
And I was like,
okay, it's so fucked up because in my head, I was like, that means it's good.
That means this is good bread.
I'm just like, as I should have been there earlier.
So I was just overhearing the fucking grandma and then the lady's like, oh, you just need to go buy it.
I'm like, at like this day, at this time to guarantee you're gonna be able to get it.
And you're like, oh, are you gonna, are you gonna have any more?
Cause like, it was like, you know, there's still like five hours left at the farmer's market.
And you're like, no, we just, all the stock we brought.
And I'm just holding my bread and I'm like,
be like, oh my God, this shit's gonna be so good.
This bread is gonna be so fucking good, man.
I made the right choice buying this last loaf of bread.
Anyway, so I was happy because I made, that means I, well, I wasn't happy for the grandma.
Like I literally bought the last one in front of her.
I literally bought the last one in front of her, but I'm just like thinking, wow, I can't wait to try it.
I didn't have a, I did try it.
That was like the one thing I did try, but like, I didn't have like a bread knife.
Cause I didn't realize it was an entire loaf.
I, I didn't, um, I didn't realize it was an entire loaf of bread.
I thought it was sliced.
It was not sliced.
So I have to like, I got, I have like wooden knives, like disposable knives.
And I was like trying to fucking slice the bread.
Yeah, it was, it's an uncut loaf of bread, but I was just like trying to slice it with a wooden knife.
Cause I didn't have, I, it was like a disposable knife.
So I was just like trying to slice it.
I gave up and just ripped the bread.
I don't, ow, it was good.
It was a good bread though.
It was, it was like super soft Japanese bread.
It was really good.
That grandma was right.
That was, that grandma was right.
I, that I ate that bread for her.
I ate it for her.
Hello, police.
I like to report.
What?
It's not, it's free real estate.
If she wanted this, she should have been earlier.
Like she should have lined up earlier if she really wanted this loaf of bread.
The guy in front of me bought the second last loaf of bread.
The only reason why I bought that was because the guy in front of me was buying the second last loaf of bread.
And I was like, wow, there's one left because he bought the second last one.
So that means it's good bread.
And then I bought it.
And then the grandma behind me reconfirmed my, reconfirmed that this was good fucking bread.
If it's anybody to blame, it's the guy in front of me that also bought.
I wouldn't buy it.
I wouldn't have bought it if he didn't buy it.
I knew it was good because there was one left because he in front of me bought it too.
Also T-Bird, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, it's your birthday.
I hope you had a good day so far.
Today was my birthday.
Um, I had to work, but now I get to watch my Kamiyoshi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear T-Bird.
Yeah.
Anyway, but yeah, so that there's a lot that happened the last couple of days.
Like I legit means like I legit have like an entire fucking, like an entire list of like updates and everything, um, going in.
But yes, today is Call of Duty Black Ops 6.
Um, I know the game I released like a couple of days ago.
I really want to try it out.
I wanted to try the game out when, um, was it the closed beta test?
Was it closed beta early access was out?
Uh, because like, you know, I heard like, it was really fun to like, how to like, you know, kidnap people and be like, Hey, what you doing boy?
So I've been wanting to try it out.
Yeah.
Try it out for a long time.
Um, I know a little bit late because everybody is trying out, trying out.
Now I heard matchmaking was absolutely terrible in terms of MMR.
So like you do really well in the first game you get to you are placed into like the hardest game of your life after that.
So like guys, if I start guys, so because of that, guys, me being bad at Call of Duty is just all acting.
So I am on purpose missing my shots.
So I don't get placed in harder lobbies.
Okay.
Like this is the excuse we're going through.
So you see me miss my shots.
It's because, um, I'm purposely throwing so we can be placed into like easier lobbies.
So we won't have a rough time at other lobbies.
So like, that's totally it guys.
I'm, I'm acting.
I'm just acting.
It's all strategic guys.
We're missing strategically on purpose.
Um, Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Asian grandma.
Oh, this bread from my childhood that I love so much is gone.
Toki tears into said bread like wild animal.
I just, I don't have a bread knife.
I can't.
I just, I don't even have furniture or kitchen.
I use disposable wooden utensils.
I have entire box of just wooden knives, forks, and spoons guys.
Like I don't even have a bowl let alone like an at bread knife guys.
I literally, I bought a trash can today.
I like, I've been so busy.
I literally, I literally Amazon ordered an actual kitchen trash can yesterday.
So I'm getting that today because you guys don't know how I've been fucking throwing my trash out.
I get a trash bag and that look, this is like the Asian way.
I, it's because this is like the Asian way.
No, it's true.
Unless it's my family.
It might be my family taught me this.
So you know how like back when growing up in an Asian family, um, you get like all these trash bags and then like you get the trash bag and then you put it in like one of the handles and then you use that trash bag as like the trash can.
So you don't waste the trash, the bags.
You don't waste like these, like all these bags and stuff.
So that's how I grew up.
So like I just use these bags and just do that and then just put trash in there.
And then after that I tie the trash bag up and go downstairs and throw the trash away.
That's how I do it.
Anyway, I got judged.
Um, I got judged, uh, two days ago.
Um, by one of my friends because I talked about that to them.
You know, I opened myself up and then got severely judged and like, you know, like, you know, shunned from society for being a freak.
So because of that, I decided to be a normal human being and Amazon ordered a trash can for my kitchen.
I mean, I got judged for not having a trash can.
So I was like, I should be a normal person and actually have a trash can to fit into society.
So there's a trash can in the lobby right now waiting for me to pick it up.
So I also, by the way, I didn't have shower curtains.
Because I was so lazy.
So I also did, I also, Amazon ordered shower curtains.
I live by myself, like, I see me.
Exactly.
I live alone.
So I was like, there's no need as long as the, the, the, the shower faucet thing doesn't like, like water doesn't go outside, like the tub, like it doesn't, the door is closed.
He's not gonna see.
The water doesn't get everywhere because the, the thing doesn't flush.
I try to make sure it doesn't phase out towards outside.
Anyway, um, I'm trying to fucking re-enter into society.
So, you know, like the wolf girl that got, like, got raised by wolves and then they gotta train her to be back.
They gotta, like, normalize her back to human society after rescuing her from the wolves.
Like, anyway, I'm trying to integrate back into society right now.
And not only is the trash can waiting for me downstairs, but also my shower curtains.
So I'm getting, I'm finally after, what is it, two to three months living here, um, I'm getting shower curtains.
Getting shower curtains.
Mega, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, you have Amazon at your fingertips.
How do you now have every single basic human essential item?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Because I started getting judged by my friends and then so, like, like, you know, because of that, I was like, because of that, I was like, all right, maybe, maybe I should, I should have these things, like, in my apartment.
Like, when you live by yourself, it's like, it doesn't, like, it's not on the top of your head, you know, when you live by yourself.
It was an unfurnished apartment before I got there, so I was like, you know, it wasn't in my head that I had to get these things.
Because I'm like, you know, who's gonna fucking see me, like, I'm fucking showering, like, the door is closed, who's gonna fucking see?
So it never, like, occurred to me that, like, shower curtains is, like, an essential item and a trash can, too, because, like I said, I don't have to, it's just me.
And then people were like, that's not normal.
I'm like, oh, fuck, okay, I gotta reintegrate into society.
Obscura, thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Damn, girl, you live like this.
I like how somebody, I like how Ozni was, like, male.
Honestly, no, no, it's true.
A lot of times, I live, it's like a hashtag male living space, like, it's very true.
Like, my walls are empty and everything.
I don't have any furniture.
Like, Ozni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, let's actually play the game, guys.
We did a 40-minute life update.
Guys, I told you, there's so much more to life right now.
But, all right, we did a 40-minute life update.
Okay, I don't know what to play on.
I heard zombies was really good.
I heard the current zombie is really good and the maps are really good for it, but we're not gonna be playing zombies because I want to save zombies as a collab in the future.
Yeah, so, I think, like, I think zombies would be a great collab in the future.
And I was actually talking to Doobie on Discord, and, like, she was, like, she loved, she was, like, super down with zombies and stuff.
Not in the near future, by the way.
We were just chatting and stuff.
So, yeah, I want to save zombies in another time.
Guys, don't, like, low expectations.
Not in the near future.
All right, anyway, multiplayer.
I want to do multiplayer because, like, I heard, I don't know you could, like, you know, like, what was it?
You kidnap people?
I don't even know what the button was for it.
Oh, yeah, Doobie's so fucked.
She's so cool.
She's so nice, too.
She was, like, telling me about her 3D setup.
Oh, my god, her 3D setup is insane.
Like, what she told me how she did all of that shit.
I don't think I could ever use that because it was, it's very expensive.
Like, when she was telling me the setup, it's so fucking expensive.
I was, like, I don't know.
I can't afford that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No matter how sad it sounds, you're still my Kamiyoshi, but please get normal living spaces.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, all right, guys, we're here to get absolutely destroyed.
I don't think I have anything.
Oh, I fell by level 4?
Can I even change, guys?
Oh, wait, I can change operators?
Wait, is there any difference between operators?
Are they all the same?
Black ops, woods.
Are there any just cosmetics?
Oh, I won't beat him.
I won't beat him.
He looks so cool.
He has one eye, so you know he's not reliable.
He has one eye.
That shit, he ain't hitting shit.
Let's see.
All right, I think that's cool.
Okay, we'll go that and then I guess find a match.
Treat everyone with respect.
Okay, no death perception.
Yeah, there's no death perception.
Is that one eye debuff?
Kill order, face off, mosh pit?
The fuck is that?
Are we gonna mosh?
Okay, gun fight.
Using predetermined class to win the round.
Okay, you know what?
I fucking, I don't know.
I don't know what's a good game mode.
Wait, what do I, what do I try first?
All right, let's just, uh, let's just fuck it.
Let's go all in.
I hope the sound's okay.
I don't know if sound guy's alive.
Honestly, I'm barely, I'm barely alive right now.
When in doubt, do TDM.
Oh shit, you're right.
All right, um, let's see.
Says thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't forget to dolphin dive backwards and get a cool ass, there's a cool ass knife kill you can do?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, you are here.
All right.
How's your, oh, 24 ms.
That's what I like to see.
Um, I think like, I usually play COD for zombies, not the multiplayer.
Sorry, guys, I'm not game.
No, my bro tuber didn't grow up with COD.
Didn't grow up with COD multiplayer.
Not my bro tuber.
No, I mostly just played COD for zombies.
I didn't play for the multiplayer.
I'm gonna get absolutely destroyed.
Okay, enforcer, recon, strategist, which is, what is it?
What the fuck?
I, what?
I just, I was trying to figure out my gun.
Oh, that's bullshit.
Oh no, I have deaf, I have deaf voice on too.
So, I definitely heard that.
I was like, the fuck, what's wrong with you?
Oh, that's my teammate.
Oh my god, reload takes fucking forever.
Holy shit.
What is this?
Reload takes forever in this game.
That's crazy.
Watch this.
360, let's go.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, please, reload takes so long.
That's fucking right.
Oh, nice, he was, how much ammo do I have?
It's an LMG.
Oh, okay, I wasn't, I don't know, I just said, I saw strategist and I was like, what did I do?
What did I do?
Oh, did I send in a helicopter?
What the fuck do I do?
Oh no, guys, no, don't give me good, don't give me good, oh, this is LMG.
This is an LMG, I keep reloading.
It's, oh, I did not mean to reload.
No!
I didn't mean to reload.
It's, it's such a bad habit.
I feel like Apex and Overwatch gave me such bad habits with uh, with reloading.
I can't help it.
It's all Apex and Overwatch's fault.
All I want to do is just reload.
Oh no, I'm doing way too well.
I'm doing...
No, this is bad.
These guys are actually bad.
This is so bad.
This is bad.
They're all, holy shit.
What do you mean, like, nine one five?
How many kills have they got?
What the, how my bottom frag, how long have they been playing?
Like, how long have these guys been playing?
My bottom frag, I've just been killing people all day.
That's actually crazy that I'm bottom frag right now.
Like...
Oh, oh, get over here.
Get your ass over.
Whoa, stop running!
What the fuck?
Ow!
Where did he go?
That's fucking right.
That's what you get for running for 20 years of your life.
What a waste.
You were born to just die.
You were, you were born just to get killed by me.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
No, oh, whoa, whoa.
The god, I'm scared.
Jesus Christ.
Like, where are they?
I'm fucking, I'm just, where are they?
No, fuck, there's three!
Oh, turn down the sound effect?
Okay.
There's no way somebody's gonna just shoot me like this, right?
While I'm, please, I, is there a sound effect?
Like, I guess there's no sound effect.
I'll turn this down.
I don't know.
Wait, am I, are we winning?
No, we're losing?
How are we losing?
Oh, it's because I didn't do confirmed kills.
Like, I need to touch this.
No!
I got it!
I touched it.
It's okay.
Guys, I...
What?
How do I swap class?
How do I swap?
How do I swap classes?
I need to try another gun.
I'm not confirming stuff.
All I'm doing is just shooting my gun.
No!
Bro, they're camping!
Escape?
Where is it?
Oh my god, I can't.
Oh, press one.
Jesus Christ, they're just camping!
Those fuckers.
That's it.
I'm calling.
I'm gonna call them.
Mushy mush!
Ring ring!
That's fucking right.
Ring fucking ring.
No!
Where?
Where is it?
Okay, what's a better?
Okay, I'm gonna try the recon.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck were they?
I don't like this guy.
Oh, I still killed him though.
I still killed him.
What the fuck?
Can I destroy it?
I can't even destroy it?
Okay, nice.
I got him.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's sniper?
Okay, that makes sense.
Okay.
Oh, I'm doing my best team.
No, there's no way!
And that's me!
I was.
I was doing my best.
I wasn't bottom frag.
I wasn't even bottom frag.
I am.
Deathwishers, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Hey, Toki.
You probably don't remember me.
Oh, and you know, I decided to join the space force instead of the air force.
Oh, I remember!
You told me about your plan to be in the air force.
I finished BMT and now I'm currently in tech school.
Happy to watch you again.
And so here is some taxpayer money for thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, see guys!
Like you guys said, chat reflects the streamer.
So if this guy can get into the space program, technically, I'm just as smart as an astronaut.
We have doctors and astronauts in the fan base, guys.
Okay, let's do some quick settings.
We're all quick.
All right, audio.
What was it?
Oh, show more!
Okay, 75.
And then effects will be here.
Okay, guys.
I was- I swear to god.
I was trying my best.
I- I swear to god.
Leave this lobby.
I- I swear.
I was doing so well.
So thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Casually walks into the most obvious.
What do you mean?
Gamers, don't look down.
I don't know.
How was I supposed to know?
Gamers, don't look down!
It's not a thing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not my fault.
That's not uh, oh!
Uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Doki.
And then, I'm sorry, I don't know the rest.
Look, see?
I can read.
I- and then I don't remember.
I don't- I can read some of the characters.
Uh, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, what's- how do you sing it in Cantonese again?
Is that it?
I don't remember.
Happy birthday!
I don't remember the Cantonese way to sing it.
I remember the Mandarin way, um, because- because like, uh, when I was in- when I was in Asia, uh, um, uh, you know, there would be like family banquets and then mostly a lot of my relatives would speak like Mandarin.
So they'd still sing it to me in Mandarin instead of Cantonese.
And so I was like, was I not queuing up?
Oh, I wasn't even queued up.
So like that was like the only- like they rarely sing it to me in Cantonese.
That's why I remember the song.
Yeah, I turned off motion blur.
I'm pretty sure I turned it off.
It was like the first thing I looked at too.
Guys, it was my first game.
Guys, please.
Maybe I'll do balance.
I don't think we need ultra.
We don't need to look that good.
Um, I think that's- I think it was like view.
Yeah, motion blur.
Wait, what?
How is weapon motion blur on?
All right.
There we go.
I thought it was off.
I literally checked it before stream.
Yeah, I checked it before stream.
I don't know how it was on.
Maybe because I restarted the game.
Guys, this game- this game took me three restarts to get going.
Like, you gotta- you start the game, then you gotta log into Activision, and then after that, you need to connect your phone number on Steam.
And then after you connect it, you have to re- okay, you gotta log into Activision.
You then restart.
After you restart, you go back in, and then you gotta connect your phone number to Steam.
And you want to play multiplayer.
And then I did that, and then I restarted, and then there was another thing I had to do.
And they're like, oh, yeah, we gotta install some updates.
You gotta restart now after the updates are done.
So then I did that, and then I went back in, and then I'm in.
And then I was in.
It took so long.
Like, I just went through so many restarts today.
Yeah, it was pain.
I was like, do I really need to restart my game 500 times just to play Call of Duty?
Like, what- how do the Xbox gamers do it?
Enforcer?
What weapons do I have?
Domination.
Okay.
You want to clear your name?
Capture the zone and then- Did I get fucking- what happened to me?
What happened to me?
How do we lose C?
What happened?
That's crazy, you can- you can get- oh my god, you can get crushed.
That's actually crazy.
Now I know.
I'm looking at my map.
I remember this game.
You gotta look at your map.
Are you serious?
How fucking- Don't- don't tell me I got SBM'd already.
Like, don't tell me I already got- guys, this is my second- Oh my god, I swear to god, if I got SBM'd already, I swear to fucking god.
This is literally my fucking second game.
I swear.
No, don't do this to me.
This is my second game of the game.
Don't SBM me.
Oh god.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's so many people.
I'm so scared.
Okay, here we go.
Secure it.
I secured it.
See the people.
I'm securing.
I'm capturing.
I'm doing my job.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm scared.
I'm too scared to keep doing my job.
No, why did you do that?
Why did you leave me here?
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
No, I'm securing this.
I don't know.
I forgot to throw my nade, guys.
Is it this?
Oh my god, it's not this.
No, no, no, no, no.
I have a pistol.
No, I have a pistol.
No!
I was like, which button is the nade?
I was trying to remember where...
Oh god.
Okay, that's fine.
Q!
Oh, that's not Q!
My sticks are on me.
I was trying to press E.
Why is grenade E?
What the fuck is an E?
That's so dumb!
Why the fuck is grenade E?
It should not be.
It should absolutely...
What's on G?
Nothing is even on G.
Like...
Oh my god, nothing even is on G.
Like, what do you mean?
Oh, don't worry.
I stay...
I need a... I need a fucking... Yeah, why not G for grenade?
That doesn't make sense.
G is for armor?
Not G is for armor.
Why the fuck is it not...
I'm going.
There we go.
I did it.
I hit his E because hide?
That doesn't make sense.
Oh, hey, he has a cat.
You lost B?
No, I worked so hard.
What the fuck?
He looked like he was dead.
E for armor.
Bro, you bitch.
You're such a pussy.
You're actually a pussy.
All right.
Oh, I have 60 bullets.
If I knew I had 60 bullets, I would not be...
There we go.
I don't know if there's anybody there, but I just did it for the sake of it.
We're capturing.
We got it.
We got the place.
What are you gonna do?
Kill this?
That's fucking right, bitch.
That's...
There we go.
Movement.
I didn't get crushed.
How did he come over here?
How did he...
How did he get over here?
How did he... How did he get over here?
Oh, wait, what's this?
I'm swapping.
The settings, I...
I can't.
I can't do grenade E.
E makes me just want to pick stuff up.
I can't.
We don't need armor.
I see it.
I press E out of reflex.
We don't need armor at this point.
There's no need.
I'm just like, let me pick it up.
Let me fucking pick it up.
It can't be bad.
This is so bullshit.
It actually is one of them.
Oh my god.
I hate that it's E.
I hate it.
I re-binded it.
It was actually causing me too much fucking stress.
Oh my god.
I'm just not used to... Like, E is use inventory.
That's what E is for me.
It stands for use inventory.
Okay, we still have the last guy.
You should have seen the last guy.
You should have seen that guy.
Hahaha.
It's reflex when you use...
Guys, it's literally reflex.
I've been using E for use item for years.
How am I... And now it's not?
You know, like now it's not?
What do you mean it's different now?
Oh shit.
Oh god.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No!
It's muscle memory.
It's literally muscle memory.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
There, see?
Look, now I don't fucking accidentally grenade myself after re-binding.
We don't need armor.
We never needed armor.
Okay, it's fine.
Fine, we're reclaiming.
Oh my god.
It is.
It's literally the standard for gaming.
They just never fucking... They never swapped.
It's literally like...
Gaming 101.
G for grenade.
Not G for fucking garmor.
Oh shit.
Whoops.
I hope there was no friendly fire.
I don't know.
That would be awkward.
Losing alpha?
Are we winning?
Bro, we're fucking winning.
I'm gonna do it.
Wait, you can't flank there.
I love garmor.
Like, who the fuck does G for garmor?
That makes zero sense.
Okay, that guy's dead.
That guy's dead, dead.
Whoa, nice.
Okay.
Oh, I love the movement though.
The movement's so smooth.
Wait, oh my god, that guy was dead!
That guy's... Oh, yes, I got him.
A?
Who the fuck is at A?
Oh, you are at A.
Do you have armor?
Doh, what?
You can run backwards?
Running backwards is so weird.
I don't know if I can do it.
I don't know if I can do that.
It's just so unnatural.
Running backwards?
I know it's like...
It's like low-key, like...
a thing in this game, but it's so weird.
I'm not used to just running backwards in general.
Wait, what?
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Nice.
Wait, who's in this?
Who's in this area?
Nobody.
It's ours.
I love the movement.
It's so smooth.
Oh.
It's so... oh my god.
I need to remember, like, you can also, like...
you can also, like, dive in this game.
Like...
Wait, where is he?
Ha ha ha!
That's right, you tr...
Whoa!
No!
It's okay.
Okay, we're winning anyway.
We're winning.
Oh my god, the time to kill.
Go, go, go, go!
Don't be a pussy!
Go!
Don't be pussy!
Oh, shit!
Okay, I got stunned.
Never mind, I'm a pussy.
Ha ha ha!
Wait, I'm getting shot from behind.
What?
There's a...
Turn around!
You're...
Oh my god!
How did we let this one guy...
do that?
Oh, we still won.
Like, turn around!
I'm getting shot.
Where?
Where do I get armor?
It wasn't me, guys.
I didn't die, so technically I'm winning.
Ha ha ha!
Alright, nice.
Does it even tell you how many kills you got?
It's just, like, objective.
Oh, I have 33 limbs!
Wait, how many do they have?
Wait, what does the score mean?
What is the score?
What is...
Armor is only in one game mode?
Exactly!
That is why I fucking...
unbinded armor.
Oh, I get new loadouts!
Fuck yeah!
Is this, like, play to win?
Wait...
Is this play to win?
I can make my own class?
Wait, how do I do that?
Guys, give me the best loadout.
Guys, what loadout would work for me?
Genghis, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, I think the last time!
It's like...
Who's breathing him?
I think he's on his Xbox right now.
Okay, guys.
What's the question?
I think he's on his freaking Xbox.
Alright.
Guys, what gun should I do?
Shotgun?
Oh yeah, the RC car!
Wait, I can't even think.
Wait, what do you mean?
Wait, I can't...
I'm so confused.
There's so many things.
Wait, are we in?
Wait, I was trying to customize!
Rain in the fire?
Is he okay?
Is he on his Xbox?
He has to be on his Xbox.
There's no way.
Do I have...
Guys, what gun?
What do I get?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
What do I get, guys?
What do I get?
3?
Oh, the shotgun.
It can't be that bad.
We're gonna try.
We haven't tried...
What is this?
Oh, is this deathmatch?
Oh my god, maybe I shouldn't do shotgun.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait, let me...
We're not doing shotgun.
Everybody...
Yeah, we're not...
Guys, we're not doing shotgun after that.
Oh shit, with a sniper.
Yeah, after that, that was...
Yeah.
That wasn't it.
That was absolutely not it.
Wait, how the fuck?
I can't even kill anybody.
Nobody's alive for me to kill.
Wait, this is not fair.
Oh my god, he already has a zombie thing.
Oh my god, why did I choose 5?
Guys, how do you...
Guys, you can't snipe here!
Okay, not 5.
No, you can't snipe here.
Like...
Bro, everybody's...
Everybody's so...
That dude is prestige.
What does that even mean?
Because I can't snipe here.
Oh.
Oh wait, he has this little bazooka.
Wait, this looks like an R9.
Is this an R9?
Oh my god, where are people at?
No.
Please let me...
No, he's just camping.
Wait.
No, I'm in the tryhard lobby now.
No.
No, I did too well.
That's not what I wanted.
No, look at him.
Look at him go.
They got me.
They actually...
Look at his movement.
They actually got me.
Oh, you think you got good movement too?
What?
How much damage did I do?
Oh my god.
Wait, is this gun bad?
Welcome to SBMM.
No.
I can't believe it.
Guys.
They got me.
It's like God SBMM.
It's so hard.
Okay, this gun is not it too.
What is this gun?
You wouldn't tell when someone is a god player.
Holy shit.
Bro, is he buddy hopping?
Is this man buddy hopping?
Holy shit.
He's fucking buddy hopping.
That shit's crazy.
How does he buddy hop in this fucking game?
That's crazy.
No.
He was so low.
Guys.
We're fucked.
We already made it.
It took me two games.
It literally took me two games.
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
Wait, did I kill myself?
Whoops.
I thought I threw over the car.
I thought I did this.
I thought I did that.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
That's cool.
Oh my god.
Actual buddy hoppers.
Guys.
Guys, please.
This is my third game.
This is an apex.
Everything is apex.
You put your mind to it.
Everything.
They're all apex.
Oh my god.
This is not what I expected so soon.
When they said it only took one game.
And then I didn't take one game.
I thought I was safe.
In the end, it only took two games.
Who would have thought?
It was actually two games.
When they said one game, it was two games.
What the fuck?
Oh no.
Oh my god.
That's a fucking thing.
It gets worse.
Is my team winning?
Oh thank god.
I'm just there for the ride.
Bro, this guy is actually insane.
This guy is actually insane.
Look at him jump.
He's just fucking everywhere.
His movement is crazy.
Is that omni movement?
I don't even know what omni movement still is.
But I just know that guy is fucking insane.
He's literally solo carrying.
This...
He's like solo carrying right now.
Oh my god.
Yeah, no shit.
Look at that fucking go.
Bro, he's like literally sliding.
Is there friendly fire?
I can't tell.
I don't know.
I don't play a lot of COD other than zombies.
Zombies don't have friendly fire.
I'm so scared about that guy.
Bro, that one guy is scary.
That one guy.
That guy that looks like Viper in Valorant.
Woah!
Get out!
What the fuck?
Wait, I got a limb.
Woah, woah, woah, woah.
How?
I don't know what I'm doing.
He's here!
Please, I'm first seed.
Don't come in!
That's fucking rude.
I'm the main character now.
I got him.
Wait, there's a bitch?
We got him, boys!
We did it!
Oh my god.
Alright.
You know, all I'm saying is that this is my second game.
This is my third game.
And I think I'm doing pretty well.
In a sweaty lobby.
I'm adapting, chat.
I'm adapting.
It's all about adapting to your surroundings.
Oh my god.
I'm trying so hard to adapt right now.
I'm trying.
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm trying my best to adapt to my situation.
Look, I'm adapting.
It's all about adaptation.
Wait, where is he?
What the fuck?
You can shoot from all the way there?
What?
You Valorant player!
Oh my god.
What gun is that?
Wait, what gun is that?
A GPR?
Wait, I don't want to use GPR.
Oh no, they're winning now.
Oh no, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh no, they're winning now.
I'm so sorry, team.
I'm confused.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
What the?
No, I got confused.
No, I wanted a nade.
Do I have that?
C9.
What is that?
The GPR?
I don't even know what that gun...
No one's getting the point.
I thought they would get the point.
I'm too scared.
I'm too scared to get to the point.
It's a level 30?
I'm level 4!
What's the other best gun I have?
Maybe we should check our loadout real fast.
Guys, I'm just a baby.
I'm just a little guy.
I'm literally just a little guy.
What do they want from me?
No more ammo.
Is my current gun the best gun right now?
That sucks.
That's rough.
That's actually rough.
This gun is the best gun I have.
I'm literally level 6 fighting at level 30?
Just from one good game.
That's so fucked.
I'm literally a baby.
Level 6 in a level 30 lobby.
Why did they do this to me?
I have zero attachments.
I just unlocked...
I just unlocked custom loadouts.
Oh shit.
He scared the shit out of me.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Hey guys.
I'm not okay.
I need to pick up my teammates.
I need to mooch off my teammates' weapons.
Oh my god.
Oh thank god there's no fall damage right now.
No, it's you.
Get shit on.
It's you.
Oh my god, I don't know how.
I should've got his gun.
Wait, I could've.
Does his gun still exist?
How do I get his gun?
What's the control?
Is he still here?
How do I F?
Oh my god, this is it.
Oh my god, I have his gun.
I'm literally him.
I hope I can live for one second so I can use his gun one time.
That's all I want in life.
I just want to use his gun once before I get absolutely destroyed.
I'm literally him.
Please.
Let me use the gun once.
I just...
Please.
No!
I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
When did I die?
You fucker.
I just wanted to use it one time.
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so fucked up.
Class.
Get this fucker.
I need to find him.
We need to find him, chat.
I need to bootchop his...
No!
I need to find him.
I need his gun.
I just want to be him for like one time.
I want to know what it's like to have a level...
I want to know what it's like to have a level 30 gun.
What's this?
Is this a good gun?
No.
I don't know.
I don't know what I have.
Whoa.
It definitely has attachments.
It has attachments.
That's a gun.
It's him.
No!
But he has an attachment though, so it was such a good gun.
It was technically a good gun.
He had attachments.
No!
Look, I just need a good gun.
I need a good gun.
God.
I just needed a good gun.
That's really it.
Wait!
Yes!
As long as the fucking viper guy didn't get...
Oh, that's good.
Wait!
Wait, oh wait.
Oh, he's good.
Wait, is that the sniper?
Holy shit.
Was that the sniper?
Is that gun five?
That's a try.
Yeah, that was my game three.
That...
That was my game three, chat.
This was my lobby.
I...
Just...
I'm only, not because I'm talk salty or anything.
Because game three, I got put in a level 30 lobby.
Like, I'm literally level six.
Like, what do they want from me?
Like, what the fuck do they want from me?
Like...
I...
I don't have any attachments.
I don't understand.
I don't even have attachments on this poor little guy.
He's just a little guy.
Look how tiny he is.
Look how tiny this kind of gun is.
He's just a fucking little guy.
Okay.
Do I have loadout on it yet?
Do I have anything?
Bro!
What do you mean?
What do you mean it's locked?
Okay.
Alright, let's put something on it.
Let's like...
I don't know.
Let's put...
Let's put like a fucking scope on this at least.
Let's just put stuff here.
You know what?
Let's make this little guy just a little bit bigger.
You know, let's give him some enhancements.
Like...
Doki, he's...
He's average, Doki.
He's average.
He's not a little guy.
I mean, did you not...
Did you not see what all the other guys had?
Oh my god, those other guys.
Wow.
Compared to those other guys.
Wow, that's a little guy.
That's...
Might want to mute lobby chat just in case they say anything bad.
By the way, any chances for matches with Drago in the future?
Can you guys think of a super chat?
Yeah, we're gonna have custom matches after this.
After me checking out the multiplayer.
Don't bully the little guy.
But it's not about...
It's the motion of the ocean.
Right?
Is that...
Is that it?
Alright.
Wait, I wanna...
Multiplay.
I wanna...
What are some good game modes?
Guys, what should we try?
I don't know.
I don't even know which one we tried.
What should we try, chat?
TDM?
Wait, what's TDM?
Team Deathmatch?
Okay, let's try Team Deathmatch.
I like the gunplay.
Get to kill.
Trash talk.
Immediately dies.
Cry.
Repeat until matches.
Thank you for the super chat, Gordon.
Thank you.
Alright.
Team Deathmatch.
Have I not played Team Deathmatch yet?
Alright.
People said we should mute it.
But like...
I like to be wild.
Like, what's so weird?
It can't be that.
I feel like nobody even talks.
Anyway.
Nobody even talks.
Oh, maybe I should...
You know what?
Nobody even talks!
And then suddenly...
Suddenly...
Something happens.
Something bad happens.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe.
They don't until they do.
Alright.
Did I mute it?
I don't even know.
Okay.
Nothing until...
Something happens.
It's Call of Duty.
It only takes one gamer.
It only takes one gamer to make it happen.
Alright.
You're right.
It's Call of Duty.
I almost forgot we were playing COD.
I almost forgot.
We were playing COD.
Guys.
What lobby am I in this time?
What?
Guys, I need to know.
What lobby am I in right now?
I...
How bad is my lobby this time?
Hey.
I like the sliding.
It feels so fluid in general.
Wait, what?
He's above me?
There's somebody above me.
There's a freak above me.
What the fuck?
Who is this?
He has a nice skin though.
Oh.
Where is he?
He's moving a lot.
What the fuck?
Where are they?
Oh, wait.
Did I like fail?
Oh, I failed.
How the fuck did he get 77?
I literally just joined the game.
I was like...
I just got here.
How is it 77?
Okay.
I am just a little guy.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Is there another guy here too?
Am I killed?
I think I killed him like four times.
Is he back?
Yeah, this is the same guy that I...
Oh no!
I almost got him again.
My god, why did I fail?
No.
I just didn't expect him to show up a fourth time.
It like literally came out...
I don't know.
For some reason, I just didn't...
I didn't expect the fourth time for him to appear.
For some reason.
Four was just not the number I can see.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
I'm still winning this fight.
I wanna steal somebody's gun.
This poor guy.
I've been cyber bullying him so hard.
Oh shit!
Oh no!
I almost got him!
I almost knifed him too!
I ran out of ammo.
Okay.
No, we almost got the melee.
It was so close.
It's so hard to like pay attention to my map at the same time.
Is he gonna come over?
He's not?
Bitch.
I'm not used to like looking at...
Yes!
5 -1!
That's all I'm gonna say.
5-1!
Bro, this poor guy.
Let's go.
We got 5-1.
The clutch.
Good shit.
That poor guy.
I literally just got in a cyber bully one person.
That...
That poor one guy.
How?
How would my SVM take me back to ELO hell?
All I did was kill one person.
That's all I did.
It was just one guy.
Oh, all it takes is one bad day.
Okay.
What other game?
Oh, wait, shit.
Which one?
Okay, that was a good...
That was a good team deathmatch.
What other game mode is fun?
Use him to look better.
We did kill confirm.
That's our first game.
You're gonna... No!
Don't say that!
I just got out of ELO hell.
Don't say that.
Don't...
No!
Search and free-for-all?
Okay, we'll try free-for-all.
Alright.
Don't say that.
We just got out.
You must face your crimes.
Wait, I love gun game!
Wait, I wanna do gun game so I know what it's like to actually have a gun.
Like, in game.
Wait, sorry.
So I know what it's like to have a pay-to-win gun.
That's what I meant.
Wait, which one's gun game?
Which one's gun game?
Gun game.
Which one is it?
I love gun game.
Is it kill order?
While keeping your HP?
No, not yet.
There isn't?
No!
They don't have gun game?
What the fuck is hardcore, bro?
Not yet?
Is it gun fight?
Oh, no response.
No.
No!
I can't believe they don't have gun game.
Gun game is so fun.
Yeah.
Gun game is like...
Like, the most...
What's the word?
Like, the staple of FPS games.
No, we're not doing hardcore.
We're not doing hardcore.
Guys.
Guys, we got absolutely demolished by that one level 30 guy.
Like...
Guys, it's not gonna be a good day for any of us if I'm going hardcore.
It added two months later?
Why?
Gun game is like the best game mode out of any... I think gun game is one of the...
Wait, I have free for all and hardcore?
No, don't say that.
No, oh my god, I got gas lit.
That's fucked up.
Only I'm supposed to gas lit.
We fucked up, guys.
This is it.
Alright.
I'm so excited for free for all.
We're gonna see...
We're gonna see how...
Free for all, I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get camped.
Alright, what...
We'll do one more game mode and then we'll open up customs for dragoons.
What's after...
What do you do after this one?
I'm gonna use the bathroom too.
I'll be right back.
I don't have a game yet.
Is the game already dead?
I'm like...
If I don't get a match within five seconds of queuing...
Dead game.
Dead game right there.
Alan, Kaz, Duck, Byte, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Broku, thank you for the gift.
True.
This game came out three days ago.
Dead game.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Free for all.
I can't wait to get absolutely camped.
Literally, how could this be the...
Oh no, no, that's not...
No!
I didn't mean to!
Maybe I'll try sniper again.
Okay, that's not fair.
Wait, what?
Out of...
Elimination for that?
How?
Wait, stop!
This is fucked.
Okay, well, this is fucking...
I can't.
I...
Why?
Get me back on my...
Get me back on my one trick.
Get me back!
Get me back on my one trick gun.
I can't.
I'm a one trick.
I'm a sad one trick.
Wait, what?
That's not fair.
Wait, did I get a kill from...
I don't even get kills for assists.
Oh my god, kill stealer.
Look, to be fair.
And they shoot me?!
And they shoot me first?!
Okay, to be fair, I was trolling in the first three games.
I...
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think I like free-for-all.
At least free-for-all fucking sucks.
You bitch!
These spawns fucking suck!
Okay.
These spawns are bullshit!
Guys, I'm not mad.
I'm just criticizing the game.
That's different.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
I hate these spawns.
Where the fuck did he go?
Oh my god, where the...
I fucking got lost!
I got lost in the sauce!
Okay.
Give me your gun.
Oh my god, give me your...
No!
Please!
Please, I need your gun!
I'm just a baby!
Give me your gun!
I need your gun!
I need to mooch off your guns!
No!
I'm not last, at least.
Please!
My guns are dog shit!
I need to mooch off of better guns!
I don't even have skins!
Give me your gun!
No!
Please!
I don't even have cool skins!
Give me your gun!
I'm just fucking scavenging guns right now.
No!
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't even know what gun I have.
I'm just like, give it to me.
Like, I don't care.
I just need something.
Like, I don't even care what I have.
Just give it to me.
Please!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'm fucking out.
Wait, how am I slow?
How am I...
I'm going as fast as I can!
Like...
No, but it has a cool skin!
It's not the same chat.
It has...
What?
Did I not get that?
Oh, I did.
Oh, he threw a nade.
It's not the same.
It has a cool... Oh, nice!
It has a cool skin, so it raises my FPS level.
Guys, I don't know if you know that.
Cool skins only make you aim better.
Okay.
What the fuck?
What happened?
Oh, I can close the door!
I accidentally closed the door on myself.
I'm so fucking stupid.
I was like, what?
Oh, give me your gun.
Give me your shot.
Fucking...
Give me your gun.
No, you were using a pistol!
Give me back my other gun!
What if I just...
do that?
Where is he?
Wait, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Wait.
Is that him?
Okay.
I didn't know where he was gonna land.
He threw it.
He ver-naded it.
That's actually so bullshit.
He actually ver-naded it.
That's crazy.
That's...
He actually ver-naded it.
What the fuck?
Guys, not bottom frag though.
That's all that matters.
Oh my god, that's not fair.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't see him.
He cooked.
He knew he was gonna die.
That's crazy.
That was a crazy play that he did.
He knew he was gonna die too.
Oh my god.
These spawns are so bad.
Is this free for all?
These spawns are fucking terrible.
Where am I getting shot from?
Wait, I got shot.
No!
Oh, it's so close.
What the fuck?
It has a cool skin, so it raises my gamer level.
That's fine.
Fifth place!
Not bottom frag!
That's okay.
Not bottom frag.
That's all that matters.
Alright, that's all I care.
I'm nearly level seven!
What the fuck?
Slothy!
I'm actually the baby of the sloth.
Everybody's like level 32, 38.
Like, I'm just a little kid.
I'm just a fucking little kid.
This is why I was stealing all the guns.
Like, that's not fair!
That's not fair.
I'm actually a child in this lobby.
I swear, I'm pretty sure these guys have been playing since launch too.
I'm just a child.
They'd be like, hey guys, are you guys all ready to have a good time?
And then they're all like, nine foot tall, and I'm like, hey everybody!
Good game everyone!
GG's have fun guys!
They can spell the new thing.
And they actually fucking had money on their fucking gun.
Jesus Christ.
When can I unlock this?
When can I unlock anything?
Also, Brian and Arctic, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh my god, when can I have a different gun?
Alright, do I have anything on this?
How do I edit this?
It says what level?
What does it say?
How?
Have a new SMG?
I do?
Oh, is the KSV good?
Is it good?
Oh, I don't even have anything on this.
Is the KSV good?
No?
Okay, then what's the point of looking at it?
What's the point of looking at it?
Okay, we'll do one more of these matches and then we'll do custom lobbies.
Alright, which one guys?
We'll do one more and then we'll do custom lobbies.
Which more?
Which one?
We'll search and destroy.
Teams alternate between... No, guys!
That sounds difficult.
That sounds like... That just sounds like you want me to play Valorant, guys!
That just sounds like you just want me to play CSGO!
Guys, if I want to defuse a bomb, I will boot up Valorant or CSGO, guys.
Take turns.
Oh!
I think we did this one.
TDM is the only game.
We'll do one last TDM then.
Ken say thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Toki, Toki, wake up!
Toki, your dog is cracked!
I called him!
Thank you for the super chat!
I like how people were like, there's only one game, Motoki, and it's just Team Deathmatch.
There's no other games in Call of Duty.
Nobody queues for anything else.
Alright.
Come on.
Come on!
Give me... Come on!
Where is my... What do you mean searching for a match?
I literally queued up... Oh, there we go.
Oh, there you go.
That took me like 15 seconds.
Dead game.
Dead...
Wow, dead game right there.
That should've been an instant matchup.
Game's dead.
15 seconds!
What is this dead game?
Oh, hey, Russia.
Alright.
Oh, wait, am I failing again?
God damn...
Guys!
Stop rage quitting!
Guys, I need you guys to stop rage quitting.
Oh, fuck!
Please.
I literally just showed up.
I'm just a little guy.
I swear, if I fucking press tab and I see like 800 fucking...
Oh my god, bro.
Oh, thank god, there's a level 1 and a 5 on the enemy team, but there's a level 70 on my team.
Like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Bro...
Level 70, that's like the highest I've ever seen.
Where do I go?
I don't know this map.
This map is confusing.
Like, where do they spawn?
Why do they spawn behind us?
Please, I need them to die closer so I can steal their guns.
Alright, nice.
I don't know what gun this is, but it looks like a good gun.
Wait, where did he...
Oh, shit!
Wait, where did I get shot from?
Where the fuck did I get shot from?
Wait, is this the same guy?
I can't tell if they're the same gun, guys.
Wait, where did he go?
Where did this guy go?
What?
Where did this fucker go?
I know there's level 70s in my lobby!
I need one...
I need one of your guns!
I know there's level 70s here.
I know you have the most fucking stacked gun in this lobby.
I need it.
Oh, no.
This is just a Hail Mary toss.
Okay, nice.
Give me your gun.
Oh, it has a skin.
You know it's good because it has a skin.
Whoa.
I don't want to go up that ladder.
That ladder looks so dangerous.
It's like...
Oh!
Fucking shotgun!
God damn it!
My ass kicked.
I can hear them.
Oh, this is such a big map.
Oh, thank god.
I swear to god.
If that was a shotgun, I swear to fucking god.
I was gonna...
I'm going gamer.
It counts.
I should reload.
Just in case.
I don't trust myself.
Where the fuck...
Are we even...
Where am I?
Where are they?
Oh, I don't like being in the open here.
This makes me feel scared.
Like, so open and vulnerable.
Okay.
Nade!
Give me a gun!
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's such a good gun!
No!
That was actually a good gun!
Don't matter now.
I won!
I didn't kill her again.
I know what she looks like.
I remember what you look like.
I'm gonna get you.
I need your gun.
This is her gun!
Somebody already stole it!
They had the same plan!
They had the same idea!
Somebody already stole the gun!
How is that possible?
I just...
Wait, what?
Oh my god, I was like, there's somebody here.
But I was so confused as to where.
Jesus Christ.
Wait, that's level 2?
What?
I looked away.
I looked at the map.
I looked at my chat.
At that moment.
That moment she knew she fucked up.
No!
Can't help looking at you guys!
Can't help it!
I am trying to be a good streamer.
I'm just trying to give you guys attention.
I'm getting fucking destroyed right now.
Ever since I lost that one gun.
It just hasn't been the same.
It just hasn't been the same, guys.
Ever since that one gun disappeared.
Everything went downhill.
I don't know anymore.
What the fuck?
I scanned the area!
Give me your gun!
How do you fucking get out of here?
Wow!
Oh my god!
I thought he was my teammate!
I legitimately thought he was my teammate!
Cause like...
There was a guy next to me and then there wasn't?
And then the guy disappeared?
I legitimately thought he was a buddy.
I thought he was just a cool guy.
Hanging out with me.
I wasn't blind!
I legitimately thought he was a friend!
They move sometimes.
I thought we were holding hands!
Being like, we're gonna die together, soldier.
We're gonna die together!
You know, like...
Oh wait, that's not it.
When did you get this gun?
Wait, I got a green dot.
When did you change your gun?
Where is everyone else?
I'm so confused.
I'm like looking at my map and I don't see nobody.
What the fuck?
Everybody's killing things!
But I see...
They're all dying too fast!
Please, let me join in!
I wanna have fun too!
No!
The one time I found somebody.
No, I just wanted to have fun.
Where are they?
Come on!
I swear, it was me just running around trying to find one person.
Like, where is everybody?
I did it!
No fun for this.
I just wanted to find one person.
Average god experience.
Why is there...
Oh god, the level 70 left.
For this poor team.
This poor fucking team.
I'm pretty sure half of this lobby was filled.
Did that team...
Oh my god, level 7.
How did they get level 70?
How?
How did they fucking get level 70?
I'm barely...
I'm just level 7.
After 2 hours.
Alright, private match.
Create private match.
Alright, guys.
How do we do this?
I wanna invite you guys.
Uh...
Game setup lobby.
Wait, let me figure this out.
I gotta...
Let me...
Let me figure this out.
Game setup.
Oh my god.
Oh,
I have the code.
Okay.
Um...
Game setup.
Team deathmatch.
Map.
What map do we want for game setup, guys?
Guys, what map do we want for team deathmatch?
Guys.
There's...
Vault, subsonic, Berkuda, and warhead.
Which one's the best one?
For team deathmatch?
Team deathmatch.
There's no shipment.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
There's more maps.
Sorry.
There's a scroll.
There's a scroll at the bottom.
Sorry.
There's Babylon.
I was like, there's only 5 maps?
Jeez.
Call of Duty went downhill.
There's shipment.
Wait, is there shipment?
There's no shipment.
Okay, now I know there's no shipment.
There's lockdown, payback, protocol, red card, rewind, SCUD, skyline, subsonic, vault, berkuda.
There's no shipment.
I know for sure there's no shipment.
I know for sure.
I'm literally looking at the maps.
I don't see a shipment.
I see a lot of red card.
Red card, lockdown.
Is there lockdown?
I think there was, right?
There's low town.
Sorry, low town.
Guys, you don't even know there's no lockdown?
Pretty sure I'm at the bottom.
Yeah, I'm at the end.
Yeah, there's no shipment or a nuketown.
There's subsonic.
There's red card.
The shipment in this game is Babylon.
There's Babylon.
You want Babylon?
Babylon?
Red card.
We want...
Sorry.
Alright.
Which map doesn't suck?
If they all suck, which one doesn't suck?
There has to be a map that...
Oh, wait.
You guys are COD players.
Nothing makes you happy.
I forgot.
You're never satisfied.
None.
Okay, we'll do subsonic.
True.
Okay, subsonic.
What are the rules?
Okay.
Score limit, 100 points.
Advanced points per death player.
Unlimited.
I'm trying to see if there's anything we can...
Gameplay.
Wait, there's health steal?
Wait.
Oh my god.
There's health steal.
I'm putting...
I'm putting health steal on.
I'm gonna put health steal on.
I'm gonna do it.
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
Dice.
Oh no.
God, this sucks.
Alright, we're gonna play...
Hey, it's almost Halloween.
We're gonna do vampire mode.
We'll do 150 points.
Alright, the moment I put the screen on...
There's gonna be the code.
Alright, I'm gonna put the code on my screen.
Okay?
Okay, I think this is the code.
I'm gonna put the text on my screen.
Wait, I might have put the wrong code.
Let me double check.
Okay, wouldn't it be funny if I gave you guys the wrong code...
and somebody actually had that code up...
and you guys just accidentally joined this random man's code?
Alright, here.
That's the code.
Why is there still...
Okay.
Alright.
That's the code.
Holy shit.
Wait, okay.
Alright, CJ, I'm gonna put you...
over here.
Alright.
Let me make sure.
Whoever has a lot...
I'm gonna make sure I get...
I think that's full now.
Guys.
Okay, guys.
I need you guys to die in front of me...
so I can...
Give me your best gun.
And then, like...
I need you guys to give me your best gun...
and then, like...
die in front of me...
so, like, I can...
so I know what it's like.
I know what it's like...
to, like, have a good gun.
That's all I want.
Oh, wait, I can...
Wait for custom match.
Wait, which is a good gun?
Wait, I can put on guns.
Which is the best gun, chat?
Guys, they're all unlocked.
Which one is it?
What do I do?
Guys, which one?
Which loadout?
Which is the best gun?
Okay, I need a theory craft here.
Which one?
SMGs?
The AME?
The Goblin?
Guys, the fuck does any of this mean?
Where's the Goblin MK2?
Oh, is it this?
Oh my god, is it this?
Create new build.
Is that... am I... that's not... wait.
That's not the Goblin MK2.
Okay, how do I...
put it on my gun?
Okay, I got it.
The Goblin MK2.
And then we'll...
we'll edit this.
And then...
Okay, which is my...
Wait, is that not the Goblin MK2?
Okay, what attachments, guys?
What do I put?
Guys, we gotta craft the best attachments in here.
What do I put on?
Just put random words in.
Just shout out anything and then I'll figure out which one's dot.
Is it this one?
Like, where's the red dot?
Oh, there it is.
That's the red dot.
Okay.
Just say random words and I'll put it on.
I'm figuring this out.
Yes, okay, that's a red dot, technically.
Alright.
Okay.
Muzzle.
I don't fucking know.
Wait, I need accuracy, actually.
Wait.
A better accuracy.
Okay, the barrel.
Alright.
We're at a firepower.
Underbarrel.
Ooh, let's put...
Let's put more accuracy in here.
Magazine.
Extended mag?
Ooh, okay, let's...
Let's put more ammo in here.
That's right.
40!
Let's go!
This is how they won those games.
This is how they did it.
This is...
This is how they...
Wait, what?
Equip gunfighter.
Must be quick to add more.
Equip gunfighter wildcard.
Let's do it.
Let's fucking do it.
Let's...
Let's do everything.
This is it.
They...
They don't know what's gonna hit them.
They don't know what's gonna fucking hit them now.
This gun is so stacked now.
They don't know.
Okay, we're sure there's a deagle.
I need a fucking deagle right now.
I need...
Ooh, that's right.
That's right.
You don't know what's gonna fucking...
Oh my god, and I get a baseball bat too.
Let's fucking go.
Alright.
Alright, I...
I fucking... I don't care about these.
Oh wait, tactical.
Decoy shock charge.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, stim shot.
We should get a stim shot.
And then...
No, I'll do frag grenade.
A specialty.
Guys, let's...
I'm ready.
I'm so fucking ready.
What's this?
Trophy system.
War cry.
Rally your team.
Oh my god, let's... Is that like those...
Those, like, idle sticks?
What are they called?
I say as I have a fucking concert in two months.
The dicky idle sticks?
Like, the light sticks?
Yeah, yeah, let's...
Light stick.
Alright, we're good.
The pen lights.
Let's go.
It's pen light time.
Let's fucking go.
Alright, we got our loadout.
What's score streak?
Oh my god, yes!
Let's get that car in.
Let's fucking go.
Alright, I'm ready.
Let's fucking start.
How do I start the game?
Let's play.
Alright, we're ready.
We got the RC.
Fucking did it, boys.
This is what we've been waiting for.
The RC car.
The greatest build of all time.
Holy shit, this is a tiny fucking map.
What the fuck, guys?
Why is this map so tiny?
What the fuck?
I forgot how tiny the map was.
Oh no, people are already dying.
Why are you all smoking the area?
Oh my god, that was scary.
Oh my god.
The meta.
The actual meta.
Oh my god.
Everybody's just dying.
Everybody's... Wait, how do I get my baseball bat out?
How do I get my baseball bat out?
Don't worry.
Grenade!
Frag out!
Everybody's just dying.
This gun is so good!
Oh my god.
Oh, it's over.
Wait, no, give me back my actual gun.
Oh my god.
This gun is so good.
I love the way this is such a good gun.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Stop putting smoky everywhere!
I can't see!
I can't see.
I actually...
Oh wait, that's my teammate.
Please.
I can't see anything.
Stop.
This episode, daddy.
Oh my god.
Everybody, please.
I can't see jack shit.
Oh, there's so many of you.
Stop!
Unequipped!
Don't make me do this.
That's a fucking word.
They actually died to my car.
I'm mad cuz bad.
Unequipped the smokes, please!
Guys, how do I...
How do I get rid of smokes?
How do I get rid of grenades?
Gamers do not deserve grenades after this.
Gamers don't deserve grenades like we've learned.
None of you deserve a grenade now.
Like, that was actually a mistake for all of you.
Guys!
Wait, how do I...
Wait.
Go, go!
Go!
Fucking...
Yay!
We need bad names.
We need fucking bad names.
You guys picked this map!
You picked it!
I literally was like, where's what?
What?
Oh my god.
That was so...
Hey, not bottom frag.
Let's go.
As long as I'm not bottom frag, let's fucking go.
Don't ban the names.
Alright, making a new lobby.
I'm making a new lobby.
Okay.
Alright, new lobby time.
Alright, if you played already, let other Dragoons have a chance to play.
Game setup.
What?
What do you mean locked?
Oh, okay.
Game setup.
Kill confirmed.
Okay, guys.
These are the maps.
Which one?
These are all the maps.
Now don't select a bullshit map this time.
Don't...
We need a bigger map.
Guys.
Babylon?
Alright, Babylon.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna get rid of...
Okay.
Guys, is there a way to ban grenades?
Guys, is there...
What do I put friendly fire on?
Wait.
I need to figure out.
I need to figure out how to ban grenades.
That's...
No!
What do you mean I can't ban grenades?
What do you mean?
This team... You guys don't deserve nades after that.
You guys don't deserve nades after what we went through.
Wait, is that too small?
What's a bigger map?
What's a bigger map, chat?
Which one's bigger?
Red card?
Is red card a big map?
Okay, red card.
Alright.
Are you guys ready?
6-8-L-B-D.
If you played already, let other dragons have a chance to play.
It's right here.
Oh god, you guys are on Xbox.
Wait, so you guys have controller on on Steam?
You guys are trying to fucking put aim assist on?
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Are you guys ready?
It's 30... Wait, what's the max chat?
How many people can be in a lobby?
How many people can be in a lobby, guys?
32?
Alright, let's start.
I'll play like two more.
Two more games.
This is fun.
I think COD is fun for mindless, head-empty shooting.
It's a fun just pew-pew game, honestly.
Oh my god, it's soccer.
And now, now that I have my gun, it's over for all of you.
It's...
This truly is play to win.
It truly is.
It's so much play to win, guys.
Like, I now understand.
Now...
What the fuck?
Where do I go?
Like, oh my god, this gun is so fun.
Who is fucking buying any smoke grenades, you fuckers?
You fuckers and your smoke grenades.
The fuck?
Can we go on the field?
What the fuck?
It's a strat.
If you use smokes, you're using a crutch.
That's why I said it.
Use smoke as a crutch, not to actually be a gamer.
You wouldn't need to use smokes if you can aim.
That's all I'm saying.
That's right.
I said it.
If you can aim, you wouldn't need smokes.
Kofi.
It's true.
It's so true.
Using smokes is just a crutch for those who can't aim and rely on visuals.
I used smokes to ruin the game.
Oh, that's it.
That's it.
I'm ready.
Wait, where are they?
I'm fucking ready.
Get over here.
Oh my god.
Look at him.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You thought you got me, right?
No!
Wait, he did got me.
That's fucked.
Wait, I thought I saw something right there.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Nice.
Come on.
Yes.
I did my job.
Where did all you guys come from?
Mine.
What the fuck?
Oh, wait.
You're not on my team.
Yoink.
No!
I was gonna yoink!
No, stop!
Stop!
Don't make me pull this.
Don't make me pull this up.
Oh!
Oh, I dodged it.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
That's right.
Yes!
I got him.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
That's what I'm talking about.
Pure skill.
Pure fucking skill.
Got him.
I love this gun.
This gun is so good.
Something will happen.
Wait, how do you have 53?
Guys, are you guys okay?
Fucking easiest game of my life.
Yes.
So easy.
Pure skill.
They never saw it coming.
Airborne ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If you use smokes, that's a crutch.
Person who cries when they can't look.
Thank you for the super chat.
We all know.
It's play to win.
What do you mean?
I barely had good guns.
I had baby level 1 guns.
What do you mean?
The moment I got a good gun, it was over.
It was over for everybody.
Okay, let's see.
Free for all.
That's right, it's free for all time.
I'm going to make the points so obscenely high.
So we can actually play the game.
Wait, no.
I almost started a game where it's just me.
Alright, let's see.
Game setup.
I almost was just by myself.
Match starting in 3, 2, 1.
Alright, let's see.
Team.
Is it domination?
That's fun.
Or control?
Take turns attacking and defending the zone.
Is that?
I don't even know.
Kill order?
Wait, which one do you guys want?
Do you guys want control?
Or domination?
Or capture and hold the hardpoint?
Or hardpoint?
Oh wait, it's 3 points?
Is it 3 point mode?
Domination, hardpoint, or control?
Domination?
Okay, we'll do domination.
Alright, map time.
Select a map, guys.
Oh wait, I'll show you guys the map.
Guys, select a map.
It's map time.
Alright, these are all the maps.
We have...
Let's do ones we haven't done before.
Did we do Babylon yet?
Isn't Babylon small?
3-1, Skud, Skyline, Subsonic, Vault, Vercuta, and Warhead.
Babylon?
Okay, Babylon.
Alright guys, are you guys ready for the code?
Like I said, have you joined before?
Oh wait, let me make it so that...
What is it?
Round swap?
Round score limit?
Let's do 400.
Where's the next round?
400 seems a lot, right?
Is that enough?
We'll do 400.
Do you think 400 is enough?
I've been increasing this more and more.
Because I don't know.
Alright.
I'll do 400.
Is it going to take forever?
Is it?
I'll do 350 then.
400 is too low?
I'm going to do 400.
I'm going to do 350.
Guys, I don't know.
I think...
Bro, max is like...
It doesn't stop!
Max is 10,000!
We're not going to do that.
I'll do 350.
350, okay.
Alright.
J4XCF.
That's the code.
Alright.
I believe.
What is...
32 is the max, I believe.
Wait.
Oh, I was going to say.
Is this like free for all?
Wait.
Where's the other team?
Okay, it's 32.
Let's go.
I don't remember what domination was.
And the next one, we'll do...
We'll do free for all as our last game.
Free for all as our last game.
Laughing, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Glad I got to play on a team with you.
I've been stressed from work and that was what I'm glad you guys had fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I saw some goons rejoin.
Who was it?
Shame them.
Call them out right now.
Let everybody see who it was.
Laughing.
Shame them.
We're here to shame.
Shame anyone that...
Laughing.
That doesn't follow the rules.
Keep forgetting mines is like a crap.
That's fucking right.
We shame.
Type their names in chat right now.
Laughing.
What the fuck?
How many?
How many names?
Fucking how many were they?
Laughing.
Holy fuck.
That was like 20 names.
Oh my god.
I don't know what they expected from me but that was actually 20 names.
Laughing.
Every name in existence.
That was actually crazy.
I don't know how anybody can survive that.
That's for sure.
Laughing.
Someone give me a skin pack right now.
Whoa.
Laughing.
War.
War is out.
Oh my god.
Laughing.
No.
What the fuck is right there?
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Laughing.
There's so many people.
There's so many.
What do I do?
Oh my god.
This is war.
What's going on?
Is everybody okay?
Oh.
Guys, I don't feel so good right now.
Why is there fire everywhere?
Laughing.
I can't see.
I'm blind.
Oh thank god you're a demon.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Oh.
Fuck.
Guys, I think to 400.
Holy shit.
How many planes are in the sky?
Look up.
Laughing.
Guys.
How do we get this plane out?
Get it out.
Laughing.
Oh my god.
How do we even play this game anyway?
Who fucking said Babylon?
Babylon is what?
That's way too many planes.
Babylon.
Okay.
Okay guys.
I think we realized that Babylon was not it.
Laughing.
Babylon truly was not it.
Guys.
Laughing.
Oh my god.
It was not it.
Guys.
Oh we are not making it to 400.
That is way too many.
Laughing.
Grenade.
Just move out.
Get out of the corner.
We're never gonna hit 400 at this point.
When they said that 400 might have been too many, I did not realize that 400 might have been too many.
Laughing.
This is it.
I'm angry now.
Somebody smoke for me.
Somebody smoke for me right now.
Get over here.
Laughing.
I'm angry.
I need smoke.
This is the one moment where I need smoke.
This is it.
Guys, I need a smoke right now.
Yeah.
Laughing.
This is it.
Now use your smokes.
This is your moment to shine.
This is the moment to shine.
Where are you?
Laughing.
I'm fucking scouting right now.
This is it.
Guys, put all your smokes in.
This is the only way I can get a kill.
Laughing.
What's going on?
Welcome to war.
Okay, now you can stop guys.
This is too many smokes now.
Guys, I can't see shit.
Guys, please.
I'm just gonna hide here.
Nobody will know.
How will they know?
Laughing.
Unless they're fucking stream snipers.
Guys, when we hit 100, it's over.
Guys, I didn't realize we're not gonna get to 400, guys.
Laughing.
Whoever the fuck that was like, 400 is too low.
Whoever said that, whoever said that clearly, clearly was like, was fucking with me.
Laughing.
400 was definitely not too low.
Oh my God, please.
It's fine, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Oh, guys, it's okay.
I'm not okay.
Laughing.
Oh my God.
Guys, the moment we hit, okay, 150, because we're losing.
The moment we hit 150, it's over.
150 is our cap here.
And then we start free for all.
Oh my God, please.
I swear by, wherever I feel like, I'm just gonna sit here.
I'm just sitting here.
They won't know.
How would they know?
How would they know who the fuck is Bomb?
Sorry, I didn't realize.
I'm going in.
Guys, that was my car!
Go!
Go, everybody!
Alright, 150.
Guys.
Wait, I thought there was a guy right here.
What the fuck happened to him?
Did he die?
Wait, I got shocked.
Oh, he died.
This is my home now.
I'm just gonna stay here.
This is my home.
Alright, I guess this is not my home.
I guess that's not my home.
Wait, he's lagging!
Wait, that's cheating!
I don't know!
What's going on?
I got somebody!
I don't know how!
I barely can see what's going on!
There's...
What's going on?
Where is anything?
The fucking blade!
I...
Everywhere!
I spotted the smoke!
There's a fucking...
How many blades are
here?
There's more!
Get these blades out of here!
Get it out of here.
Holy shit!
There's so many blades!
Guys, we need to get these blades out of here.
Wait, what happened?
Fucking... Oh my god.
Alright, we're just gonna...
That's stream sniped!
There's no way!
Oh, he used the radar?!
Oh my god, you fucking nerd.
You fucking tryhard nerd.
This is Call of Duty.
You fucking tryhard little whore.
That's right.
Woah!
I'm playing COD.
This is the one game I can call people whores.
If there was any game where I can call people whores, it's this game.
Bro, please.
Oh my god.
This is...
Please, where are you?
Oh my god.
Oh, I died.
Stay around him, Mary.
Go around him.
Get around me.
Okay, nice.
Nice, we're fine.
Nice, I got...
Oh god, I'm okay.
I'm not though, but...
Oh my god!
Stop!
Oh my god, please stop.
Oh my god, please.
I can't.
I'm just a little guy.
I'm just a little...
Alright, alright, it's over.
I can't.
Guys, it's GG's.
Everybody, I can't.
Okay, we'll end with a bad kill.
The moment I kill somebody with a bad, it's over.
I can't.
We can't do 400.
We can't do 400 of this.
I can't.
I can't do 400 of this, guys.
400 is one too many.
Who has not shot this fucking helicopter down?
Why is this helicopter still there?
Holy shit!
What is going on?
Oh my god.
Please, I just won one.
Why is this helicopter still there?
Oh shit, false jump.
Oh my god.
I can't.
No one's letting me get close to them.
They know the moment I get this melee kill, it's over.
They know.
They're all trying to make sure.
They're all trying to make sure I don't get it.
They don't.
It's not gonna stop me.
They're all trying to fucking make sure we don't get the melee kill.
Like, don't let her get it!
The game's over!
That's right.
Yes!
Bye, guys.
Goodbye.
Got that melee.
Remember the guy that died to my melee.
Remember him.
Bro.
Get padded.
Remember that guy.
He was the reason why the game ended.
Shame.
He was the guy that ended the game for all of us.
How could you do this to us?
Alright, last game, guys.
Last game.
I'm gonna do a free-for-all for the last one.
Alright.
Private match.
Shame.
Alright.
Game setup.
Guys, okay.
Guys, don't fuck with me this time.
I need to know.
What is the biggest map?
What is...
Guys, we actually need a big map.
You guys have all gave me small maps.
Like, every single map was... Okay.
It was so fucking small.
Was the mosh pit the size of a bathroom?
Glad I got to join a map.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is Borkuta big?
Alright, Borkuta.
Okay.
Borkuta, free-for-all.
The score is 70... Okay.
60.
55.
There's no way you guys can get to 55 that fast.
There's no way.
You know what?
60.
There is a way.
There's 32 of you guys.
One of you guys is gonna feed.
Nevermind.
There is a way.
One of you will feed.
Okay.
This is it.
K9W44
K9W44 K9W44 I will kick someone out that has played this game already, guys.
Get ready to shame.
This is your moment to shine.
We're calling you out here.
Get ready to shame.
I'm ready to shame all of you.
Wait.
I need to know how to- I don't want to accidentally like doctured profile of me..
I didn't make sure.
Okay.
Okay, that's how you do it, kick player.
All right.
I remember who were top fraggers.
All right, guys.
Get rid of shame.
Call people out.
Do you recognize anybody that has played before?
Get rid...
Name them!
Name them all!
Except for... where is he?
Where is he?
Kobenny?
Where's Kobenny?
Kobenny!
Justify yourself right now.
If you're in... oh, he left.
Okay, there.
That's how you do it.
That's how you shame, guys.
That's how... that's how you shame.
He instantly left.
Okay.
Anyone else?
Anyone else ready to shame?
Anyone?
All right.
Good boy, Joe Smith.
Where are... Joe Smith!
Explain yourself, Mr. Joe Smith!
That's right!
Don't make me kick you.
Why did I...
Shame!
All right.
Not only am I gonna kick you, I'm gonna report... I won't report you.
Allen?
Allen!
Shame!
You know what?
I'm gonna report you, too.
I'm gonna...
Your username was offensive.
Shame!
All right.
Who else?
Kick and report.
You know the rules!
Dongle!
I remember Dongle!
Shame!
Um...
That not-joke-keeper killed me on RCXD earlier.
Kick them, BambiBoy.
Thank you with a super chat.
Shame their Dongle!
All right.
Who else?
Who else, guys?
Who else in here that we need to shame?
Thanks for the mad shame.
I got stuck on the largest map with a shotgun.
Back to the Zombo Camo grind.
Demon, thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Kick LL's UCK?
Where are they?
I'm ready to shame them.
LL?
All right.
Shame!
There we go.
All right.
I think we're ready.
Are we okay?
Have we shamed everybody?
I think we shamed everybody.
We have one more spot left.
Okay, now you guys are just kicking random people because you didn't get in.
Like...
Now you guys are actually... I'm pretty sure you guys are kicking around.
You're like, I didn't get in.
I'm going to shame these people.
So then they'll get kicked.
You're just like, wait, she's not even double checking.
She believes anything.
If I can't get in, no one can.
Nobody can get in.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Shame!
One more.
All right.
We have another spot in.
We got another...
We got... All right.
That's all the shaming.
Okay, here we go.
Last game.
This is the last game.
How dare you?
You're just like, I didn't get in.
I'm going to shame everybody.
And then hopefully, the more people Doki kicks, the more of a chance I can actually get in.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Last game, guys.
Last game, and then we're going to...
And then we're going to hang out.
I forgot this was free-for-all.
Holy shit.
I forgot we were playing free-for-all.
It's like, what happened?
What happened?
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
Jesus Christ.
We all just logged in to fucking die.
That's crazy.
Holy fuck.
Bro, this is actually scary.
This is so scary.
Oh, I see.
The fuck you doing there?
Oh, he got shot from this side.
Nice.
No!
I'm jinxed!
Son of a bitch!
Oh, shit.
No!
God damn it, I was jinxing.
There's so many... This is like from a game with zero players.
This was a map where I couldn't find anybody.
And now there's like 200 people.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
It's just... Everybody just literally gets spawned again.
Holy shit.
Holy fuck.
Like, literally everybody spawned in there.
That's actually...
Oh, shit!
Fucking... That's fine.
I don't know, but that was a spawn right there.
That was a crazy spawn.
Oh, my God.
That was such a crazy spawn.
No!
I'll take your shotgun.
Still got it!
I still got it!
Holy fuck, I still managed to get it.
That's crazy.
That's fine.
I take those.
Actually, I take those.
That was such a good...
That was such a good kill.
Holy fuck, I take those kills.
Oh, my God.
It's okay, I take it.
Come on.
No, I fucking knew it.
I saw you, too.
I just knew it.
I knew I was gonna get spawned behind.
I fucking knew it.
No!
Oh, my God.
No, that's mine!
Bro, I don't even think I have time to put RC car out at this rate.
There's so many things going on.
I don't think I even set it up.
Fucking hell, what is this spot?
Please!
I can't exist!
Oh, my God.
I literally can't exist.
Where is hell?
I can't exist at all.
How is somebody at 41?
What have you been doing?
Oh, my God.
What actually have you been doing?
What the fuck?
Just click heads.
What are your spawns to be able to do that?
It's okay.
I got two.
Okay.
I just got here!
Okay, I've got the double.
Wait, what?
You're not dead?
How?
Please, let me live!
There's so many people in my ass right now.
There's so many people.
Oh, my God.
Wait, what?
What?
What happened?
No!
No, the game crashed.
Oh, my God, it crashed.
Oh, my God.
No!
No, it crashed.
I can't believe this every time.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
Top ten.
Guys, top ten.
That's fine.
We got top ten.
I'll take it.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right, that was fun.
I actually enjoyed it a lot.
I think Call of Duty is really fun when you just want to shoot things.
And I also had a lot of fun just shooting things.
I just had a lot of fun being pew, pew, pew, pew.
It was definitely quite enjoyable.
Yeah, it's a nice brain-off game where you just want to shoot a lot of things and just get kills and stuff.
Just fragging out.
I had a great time, just honestly, just fragging out and just, you know, seeing where that takes me.
Hey, guys.
That's me swap over.
I'm going to swap over.
Yeah, I definitely enjoyed it.
Everyone made me do a member stream of Call of Duty.
But zombies?
Definitely not anytime soon because I want to get like I want to do as a collab.
So we'll wait on that.
And...
Oh, we have super chat reading time.
It's been a while since we...
Wait, what's this?
There's a goal sheet?
What is this?
Make super chat more fun with a goal?
Wait, really?
Oh, my God.
Wait, they have a new thing.
Wait.
Okay.
Wait, look at this.
Oh, wait.
What does it look like?
You get...
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Let me do another one.
That's so funny.
Wait.
There's...
There's a goal now.
You get nothing.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
That's...
That's so funny.
They actually have, like, an actual...
Yo, you get nothing.
What a steal.
What a fucking...
Wait, that's new.
Oh, my God.
That's cool.
That's funny.
You can set goals and stuff.
I, like, looked over.
I was like, the fuck is that?
They must have implemented that today.
That's crazy.
Give me...
Yay, nothing.
It's at the very top.
See?
It's, like, goal.
And it even has, like, a timer.
Nothing!
MrBrokenFat, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Congratulations!
You got nothing!
Let's go!
Whoa!
Shoutout to him!
Nothing!
That is...
That is the biggest goal of all time.
Nothing.
That's so funny.
I didn't realize that...
I didn't realize...
That was a thing there.
That's so funny.
The game died while I was in the middle of a knife assassination.
But GG, Doki.
Some pretty good stuff.
Hopefully, you can see more in the future.
Yeah, I definitely want to do...
More member...
I want to do more member streams of that.
Because that was, like, really fun in general.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the super chat.
Jakado, thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah, we can actually do real goals with that.
Yeah, one...
Nothing, please.
John, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Dan, thank you for the Akasupa.
Oh God, so much nothing!
Yeah, I think I...
I'm gonna wait until Gun Game is out.
I think it'll be very fun with Gun Game in general as well.
Can this nothing be used as a text right now?
Excuse me, this was a business expense.
What kind of business?
Nothing.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Mr. Stan, thank you for the super Akasupa.
Finally, a cause I can get behind.
Nothing.
The confetti.
Woo!
Let's celebrate, everybody!
Nothing!
We accomplished it!
Yay!
Thank you for making your possible.
You get nothing!
Let's
go!
Shout out to the dragons!
Thank you again.
And...
How dare you give us confetti?
I was promised nothing.
Nox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for having me on your last game.
Gigi's back to the grind.
Frosty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That was a good break from camel grinding.
Thanks, Doki.
Thank you for your super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And Kaiko, thank you for the super chat.
But yeah, definitely had a lot of fun with that.
It was a nice head-empty pew-pew type of game that I'd definitely like to play again with member goons.
If you're a member, not anytime soon though.
But I definitely would love to play it again in the future with you guys.
Especially because I can do more custom lobbies again for that.
I think I did pretty well for my first time playing Call of Duty Black Ops.
You know, when you go in with no knowledge about anything.
And then your fucking third game, you get put into a level 30 lobby.
Where everybody has all the fucking attachments on their guns.
And then I'm out here fucking vulturing and being like, give me your gun.
Just fucking scavenging dead body guns.
And just like, give me your gun.
Please, I need something.
I need something, please.
Okay, let me scroll all the way down.
T-Bird, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I already wished you a happy birthday.
That was for your birthday.
Templar, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki has the vibes of someone who likes to... Okay, I'm not gonna finish that sentence.
Oh yeah!
Okay, life update.
Let me give you guys... Before I read more...
Let me get... Wait, what's this?
Let me give you guys some...
Life updates.
Okay.
I wrote a list of everything.
When you're bored for three fucking hours at the hair salon, you write a list.
Katis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki's streams strangely coincide to my work times at the lab.
Thank you for the laughs while I wait for my spectroscopy data.
Take my last $5.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
See, guys?
See?
Chat reflects the streamer.
And that means...
If you have a degree in science and you're working in a lab...
Solving cancer or other terminal diseases...
That means I also take credit for that.
I'm just as smart, too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Before... Okay, guys.
I have, like... I need to Amazon Prime.
Guys, I need help.
Help me buy a printer.
I need... What's a good printer?
We don't need the most expensive printer.
We just need stuff...
I need to print stuff out for, like, business stuff.
Because, like, I'm tired of... I'm really tired of, like...
Taking... Like, getting my phone out at the bank and being, like...
Here's, like... I need to do a bank trans... Wire transfer...
Guys, by the way, I fucking hate...
I realize that Canadian banks are so bad...
Because we're so backwards to the fact that we have to go to the branch...
To do wire transfers.
Because, like, apparently...
I was telling one of my friends about it, and they're like...
The fuck?
You don't do it online?
And I was like, no, you have to go to the branch.
And then they're like, no, like...
And then they were telling me how, like...
Oh, yeah.
Canada is apparently one of the few countries...
Where you have to go to the branch to do wire transfers...
And do stuff at the branch.
Because they are so fucking backwards.
And... No, it's not just... No, it's not just the bank.
It's every... Almost... It's every Canadian bank.
You have to go there to do it.
And then it's not...
I don't believe the security thing.
Because if other countries can get away with it...
Like, why would, like, Canada be the only...
One of the few countries that are like...
No, guys, it's a security thing.
If that's the case, what about America?
We're literally next to America.
Like, what the fuck?
Theo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't get HP.
They're an awful brand who will break your machine...
And do everything they can to squeeze the money.
Guys, I have three hours to Amazon Prime.
Guys, give me, like, a name.
Guys, I'm looking at Amazon right now.
And I want it tomorrow.
Because I need to print out this bank stuff.
Alright, here are the results I have.
I have Canon...
Guys, I also, like, don't really care.
There's Canon PIXMA TR4720.
There's Canon PIXMA...
Wait, is this wireless?
They have a fax machine?
Who the fuck faxes?
At the Brother MFCJ1012...
DW Wireless Color Inkjet All-in-One Printer...
With mobile device and dupe.
Oh, I like duplex.
Wait, is Brother good?
Get a Brother printer?
Alright, Espon or Brother?
Guys, Espon ET280...
Wait, is it...
Okay, Espon.
Is there an Espon in here?
There's so many Brothers here.
Espon...
Espon Workforce WF...
Okay.
Don't inkjet?
Wait, what kind of ink should I get?
Brother laser.
Wait, is laser better?
What about for color?
Is Brother okay for color?
Like, laser color?
Okay, but what if I want to print in color?
Guys?
What...
Guys, but I want to print in color too!
Wait, what do I...
Yeah, what do I want to print in color?
Do you need...
I don't know, but like, I like the possibility that...
Like, I like the fact that I have options.
Like...
Like, what if...
What if it's like a life or death situation?
And like, I'm put in a situation where you gotta print...
You're like, alright, Doki.
We need you to print this out in color.
Or...
You're gonna...
Or like, somebody's gonna get it.
And I'm like, oh, but I only have a laser printer.
Wait.
You know, what if...
What if that becomes an option?
Like, there's a one percent chance that it can happen and like...
You know, I don't wanna be put in that one percent chance.
She has a point.
Yeah!
I do have a point!
It's that one percent of maybe it could happen.
Um, bye bye.
Well, I guess it's bye bye then.
Um, have I ever printed anything in color?
That's such a good question.
When did I ever need color printer?
When did I ever need a color printer for?
I'm trying to think of like... I'm trying to be like...
In what scenario, other than a life or death situation...
That I used a color printer.
What if I'm creating something?
What if... What if I'm trying to print out fan art?
Checkmate.
What if I'm trying to print out fan art and like...
I'm trying to make like a collage or something.
Yeah, room decoration.
Exactly.
What if I'm trying to print out some nice fan art of me?
And that's our gotchu.
I got you guys.
Okay, color printer.
Okay, true.
Alright.
You will legally print pirating.
You won't download a car.
Alright.
You suggest me a color printer.
Just go to the... What if it's a lot?
What if... What if I want to print out 40 fan art pieces?
Like, I'm not gonna go to the fucking store.
Guys, give me like the name.
I need the name.
Guys.
Espon, Ecotank... See, look.
Victor knows what's up.
Guys, I expect this from a member goon.
I'm joking.
Members are pretending.
Okay.
I mean, no guy has ever printed out a Lamborghini.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There you go.
Espon, Expression, Expia.
Guys, this is like an actual commitment.
I need like...
I don't know.
I need printer numbers.
Like, you got to say Espion, brother.
Like, I need a printer number.
I need to know.
Where are they?
329.
Okay, this better be a fucking good-ass printer.
Espon, Ecotank, ET2800.
Is there a scanner?
The ideal home printer?
All right.
Espon, okay.
Oh, Epson.
Sorry, Epson.
Sorry, I can't...
I can't fucking...
Just 300.
All right.
Brother.
HL.
Okay.
All right, guys.
Here are...
Oh, my God.
There's so many different...
You need a good printer.
Okay.
Get a brother and print color.
I thought I got print color.
That means I got to travel to the shop.
Why travel to the shop when I can literally just do it at home?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
We need duplex, too.
We need duplex printing.
All right.
Brother, Investment Tank, MFC.
Is that the one?
All right.
Brother, Investment Tank, MFC.
All-in-one color inkjet printer.
Up to one year of ink in box.
Jeez.
Is there wireless?
Wireless.
Is there duplex?
I need to know if there's duplex.
All right.
Well, actually, my old printer was a color printer, and I liked it.
I don't think I've ever had a non-color printer.
I don't think so.
Gray printer.
One last tank.
One tank.
Okay.
Epson EcoTank.
Okay, but does it print in color?
Brother, MFC L3.
Please no inkjet.
Wait, is laser color printer better than inkjet color printer?
Call ink or laser.
All right.
First off.
Holy shit, guys.
That's a big-ass fucking printer.
What's the difference between these two?
$449?!
Wait, am I looking at the same- No, I'm looking at the wrong printer.
They don't have it.
Sorry, guys.
Sorry, they don't have it on fucking Amazon.
Like...
Oh, thank God.
Thank fucking God they don't have it on Amazon.
You save on ink?
Guys, it's gonna take me so long to use up all the ink, guys.
All right.
Okay.
Bro, the goal from nothing came.
Guys, this is basically what- You get nothing, I get a printer.
Hey, it worked out!
It worked out.
I get a printer.
That's what the goal was.
It just works.
It actually worked.
Sweet.
Sweet deal.
What a deal, guys.
All right, what are the choices again?
We'll make a poll.
One of them was...
What was it?
Brother Ink Vestment.
Okay, this is one of them.
All right.
So, okay.
We'll have one.
All right.
We have one from which printer?
Choose your...
All right.
Which is the best Epson?
Guys.
Epson.
Oh, sorry.
Guys, we'll make them fight.
Epson Vs.
Brother.
Epson Eco Tank.
ET2.
Okay, we're going to make these printers fight.
Select your representative!
Guys.
I need you guys to select your representative.
All right.
Oh, we can't get that Epson, guys.
Because...
The only one I can get was 2800.
Choose your fighter.
Choose your printer.
All right.
Come on.
Give me an Epson.
Guys.
I need an Epson representative.
I don't have the one that people were saying.
I got the 2800.
Is 2800 okay?
I don't have a representative.
All right.
This is the other representative.
The Epson Eco Tank 2800 color.
Only one cartridge.
He actually cares what type of printer it is.
If it prints, it prints.
What a colossal waste of everyone's time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not true.
Printers for life.
If you get a good printer...
If you get a good printer, you never have to buy another printer.
Okay?
That's basically it.
You never have to get another printer for life.
Someone who has never bought a trash tier printer in their life.
We need it.
Yeah, we need a good printer.
We don't want to have bad printers.
Or we got to get another printer.
Printers never last.
Wait, how come I can't...
Oh, is it because there's too many?
Okay.
Brother.
Jay.
Okay, here we go.
And then Eco Tank.
ET.
Okay, here we go.
You guys fight.
I need to use the bathroom while you guys fight it out.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
I can't believe we're having a printer fight.
This is when we know we're getting older.
We're fighting over...
We're fucking talking about printers.
And to me, we're fighting about what printer is a good printer.
It's like when the older you get, you're like, oh yay, clothes.
It's like...
Don't say that.
I stumbled into the retirement home.
It's like, oh yes, my home.
I use the Brother MFC J4335DW.
It's a great printer for my office work.
I remember the Epson one.
It's so slow at doing things.
God, it like...
It like...
It was such a pain at the workplace, you know.
It was...
Alright.
Stating facts here.
No, don't use HP.
That shit fucking sucked at my office.
Alright.
It's Bluetooth which is so iffy.
Okay.
Let me check the Brother one if it does.
Does it does duplex?
What does it say?
Duplex.
Okay.
Duplex two-sided.
Wait, does it not?
J43...
Okay, nice.
It does.
Okay, it has duplex.
Oh my God.
Let me...
Okay.
Let me tell you guys something really sexy.
Not only is it a duplex printer, it can hold 150 sheets.
It has an auto document feeder and has a 1.8 color display.
Not only that, but the print resolution for the Brother MSC J4335DW has up to 4,800 x 1,200 DPI.
You had my attention.
Damn.
That's a good printer right there.
Oh yeah.
Top printer to me.
Skip ASMR ad.
Bye.
Oh my God.
That DPI.
Holy shit.
That DPI is so big.
Whoa.
Get the Brother.
I like how it actually got more votes now because of it.
All right.
Krio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Brother printers are made from space-age technology called Steela.
The bastard would not break.
I'm sure of it.
Holy shit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
We'll get the Brother.
The Brother printer one.
All right.
Now I need to buy a kettle.
Okay.
I don't need you guys to tell me what kettle to buy.
I just need a kettle.
I don't care.
All right.
Let's see.
Make sure this is an actual good kettle, though.
How do I...
All right.
No plastic contact.
How do I fucking heat it up?
Brothers, we won!
Brothers!
All right.
Let's see.
How do we know that's...
It has 52,000 reviews on it, so it must be good.
I don't care.
It's just a kettle.
It's fine.
It boils water.
That's all we need.
Okay.
All right.
3k people bought this.
Let's...
Henya?
Henya kettle?
Is that a thing?
Is that an actual...
Is that an actual fucking...
Oh, no.
It's the VTuber.
I thought you were talking...
Oh, my God.
I thought you were talking about the fucking kettle, Brian.
I just...
I was like...
I don't know.
I didn't know they have a kettle named after it, too.
Like...
I thought you were...
Look, I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in over my fucking kettle.
I'm telling kettle specs to me.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Papa, thank you.
Thank you.
Felian, thank you for the super chat.
ASMR stream where you just read the five specs for an hour.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'll get the Kosori electric kettle.
I mean, that looks like a good kettle, right?
I mean, it just boils it, right?
Okay.
No plastic contact.
How do I...
How do I charge this kettle?
Like...
What...
Where does it...
How do I charge it?
Does it have a charger?
Oh, you just press the thing.
I don't like that.
Wait.
Is it not...
Is it corded?
Is it wireless?
Is it solar energy?
Is there an outlet?
There's no...
Is there a wall outlet?
Okay.
I don't know.
It doesn't say.
You just press the button.
What if I don't want it to be 100?
Yeah, no kettle is wireless, but it doesn't say.
It doesn't say, like...
How you...
Where's the plug?
Show us the...
It's the...
Kasori electric kettle.
It's like, how do I...
I'm gonna re-watch this.
I'm watching the video.
Oh my god.
It's made by high quality...
Where's the plug?!
It doesn't say where the plug...
Plug it...
It doesn't even have, like...
Where's the outlet?
More stylish, the purest, no more waste.
It doesn't even say anywhere.
Can I plug it anywhere?
Have you ever used an electric kettle before?
Yeah, but there's a plug.
Am I stupid?
God, I feel so stupid.
Oh, shut off.
Oh, it's the base!
Okay, we're buying this.
Alright, I don't care.
It has 52,000 people.
I don't need a fancy kettle.
I just need a kettle.
I don't need anything fancy.
Okay, good.
Okay, tomorrow.
Nice.
Alright.
Let me make sure...
Alright, what's my payment method?
I need to make sure I'm using the right card.
Okay, I am.
Okay, nice.
Alright!
I'm placing my order.
Guys, I'm so excited.
Downstairs, I'm gonna be able to have my...
I have my trash can downstairs.
Guys, I'm gonna have an actual trash can.
Yay!
Nothing!
We did it, guys!
We bought stuff for my apartment.
We did it.
We bought things.
We finally became an adult, guys.
Alright, let me look at my...
Let me look at my list of...
My list of...
To-do lists.
Let me look at my to-do list of stuff we have.
Of like, things I want to talk about.
Oh, yeah!
I won't show you guys this.
But...
Let me show you guys.
I haven't shown you guys these before.
But it's basically the...
Wait.
Where is this?
It's basically the postcards...
For like, several events.
So, I'll be shipping them...
We'll be shipping the charity postcards.
The charity postcards haven't been shipped yet.
But they'll be shipped out next week.
And so like, we have a lot of stuff to ship out.
Oh my god, where did it go?
I was about to show you the...
Wait, where did the freaking image go?
Wait.
Where did the image go?
Okay, wait.
Reset.
Okay.
I'll show you the charity postcard and the...
Wait, where did it go again?
God damn it!
I keep accidentally like, fucking...
I keep accidentally moving it somewhere else.
Because it's such a big image.
Okay, I'll show you the charity and the Lunar New Year postcards.
Lunar New Year postcards will be shipped out soon-ish.
They're waiting for like, the remaining items to get...
To be received.
Because like, we were missing some items for the bundle.
So they're waiting for it to arrive.
But...
Here is...
Here is the charity.
I'm making it small because like...
I don't want you guys to steal it.
Here is...
Here is the...
Here is the charity postcard.
Here it is.
And then...
This one is the...
This one is the Lunar New Year postcard.
Right here.
Guys, okay, I'm making it even smaller so you guys can't steal it.
Here it is.
Here's the...
I'm gonna wiggle it too.
Wow, you can't steal this!
This one is the Lunar New Year postcard.
And Doki and NFT be like, Yeah, but then these are signed.
This is the Lunar New Year postcard for the Lunar New Year items.
I think that's all the...
I mean, we've already seen the thief one.
But yeah, that's an update regarding that.
What else?
Okay, okay, look at my...
I'm gonna look at my...
To do my...
To talk list.
Alright.
See, I have a long list of stuff I wanna talk about.
Friday's sponsor.
It's been confirmed.
I will be streaming.
The reason why it says...
It didn't have a name was because it wasn't confirmed yet.
I didn't like, you know...
I didn't like finish signing anything for it.
But we just confirmed it today.
This morning.
And it's gonna be...
Nike.
On Friday.
Yes.
That game.
What game?
You know...
The one with really big guns.
The game with...
The really...
Really nice gun physics, you know?
Like...
Yeah.
The goddess of victory.
Nike.
Very...
Very big gun physics.
Yeah, with very nice assets, you know?
Like the bullets and the...
The guns and the pew-pew.
Yeah.
That game.
So that's gonna be on Friday.
On Sunday.
I also got a sponsor on Sunday.
And it's gonna be Payday 3.
Payday 3 also reached out.
For me to...
For me to try...
Test out...
Try their new updates.
So on Sunday, it'll be a Payday 3 sponsor.
So I'm very excited.
They're both games that I really enjoy.
Yeah.
It's really cool.
I'm really happy to be reached out by a lot of different companies that I really enjoy.
To like...
You know, be paid by them to play their video games.
You know?
So it's really exciting.
I'm also taking a lot of sponsors.
Because...
Dance lessons are very expensive.
I'm...
Oh my god.
I swear, finding a dance...
Private dance classes...
Is so fucking hard.
Because they're all so expensive.
Like the lessons are very expensive.
And I don't have a car.
So I have to...
I have to take public transport or Uber.
And I was like...
Talking to one of the teachers.
And like...
I was like...
Oh, and they have this...
And they're like...
You know, it's super last minute too.
So they're like...
Oh yeah, like...
These are my hours.
And like...
This is a private lesson.
Like...
At first, I was like...
When finally a teacher responded back.
They're like, we can do it.
They're like...
You can just get a car.
I just don't trust myself driving.
Because I haven't touched a car.
I haven't drove a car in like...
Six plus years.
So I don't trust myself in driving.
So like...
And driving a car is like...
Scary for...
It's like scary when...
You haven't driven in a long time.
And...
So...
So like...
That's why...
The thing is...
When I found a teacher.
Like the teacher that finally responded to me.
And I was like...
Oh, it's just like a 30 minute...
Like public transport.
You know?
I was like...
Oh, I just need to do 30 minute public transport.
And they're like...
Oh, because it's a private lesson.
This is like my home.
We have it at my home.
Like...
I have a...
I have a personal dance studio at my home.
So you're gonna have to travel to my house.
And then I looked at it.
The address.
And it's literally in another city.
Like...
So...
So like...
It's like an hour...
Public transport.
To like...
This lady's house.
And I was like...
I was just like...
Wait a minute.
I was like...
Wait.
No.
This is...
And I'm like...
Oh, man.
But then if I take an Uber...
It's like a $30 Uber ride.
To get there.
So I was just like...
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
It's like literally the suburbs.
I was like...
Oh, my God.
Not only that...
By the way, the dance lessons...
Private dance lessons are like $150 per hour.
So I was like...
Oh, and then I have to pay like $60 to and back as well.
Okay.
If I...
I would do it if I could do public transport, you know?
I was like...
That's why I'm taking off sponsors too.
To pay off my dance lessons as well.
Because I want you guys to have a good time.
I do it for you guys.
I do it for you guys because I want you guys to have a great time watching.
I don't want to be like...
I don't know.
Frumpy when I'm dancing.
I don't know what to do with my hands and stuff.
So I have actual choreo and everything.
I'm learning actual choreo.
So that's why I'm like...
I don't mind.
Because I'm doing more sponsors too.
To pay off for the dance lessons and stuff.
And...
So like...
I was like...
Because they're actual choreo.
I have to do actual choreo and everything.
And then so like...
I was like...
Oh, fuck.
Let me find it.
So I was like...
And then I was like...
Oh, I...
I don't know, man.
Well, Min's a dancer.
So like...
It's easier for her to learn how to dance.
But for me, I actually need a teacher.
Because like...
I don't know what the fuck I'm...
Like I...
Like when I have a teacher, I obviously like...
It helps a lot.
Because if I try to dance myself, I don't know what I'm doing.
And I need the mirror as well.
Like you know when you're doing dances, you need the mirror and stuff.
So like...
So it's like...
Fucking I don't know what I'm doing.
So...
So I was like...
Oh, man.
Like...
This is hard.
And...
And then they were like...
Oh, but like...
I can...
I can like travel to you.
And the teacher was like...
I can travel to you.
And then you just need to rent a dance studio.
So I was like...
Alright, how much does it cost to rent a dance studio?
It's like $60-$100 per hour.
So I was like...
Bro, I might as well just Uber.
So like...
I'm like...
Bro, I might as well fucking Uber there.
Like it's cheaper at this point.
Like...
And Ubering is like...
The thing is Ubering is like...
30 minutes as well.
So it's like...
Um...
And so...
Like if I Uber, it's 30 minutes instead of an hour.
And like I don't have to fucking rent a dance studio.
Like...
But it's just...
But it's like $30 to get...
It's like basically paying for an hour at the dance studio.
But instead, I get two hours.
Like...
I get...
I get two hours instead.
So...
Because I'm doing two hour dance lessons.
And everything.
So like...
I'm fucking...
I'm like...
I'm just like...
Thank you Nikkei for the sponsor.
It's all going into my dance lessons.
Like...
No, it's $30 to get there.
And then $30 to get back.
So...
And also Payday 3.
Payday 3 as well.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Unironically, just hire a chauffeur or a personal driver at this point.
Probably cheaper and definitely faster in the long run.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel like it's a lot more expensive.
Because like...
They have to be like...
On call too.
So like...
You know...
What if they're not there?
What if like...
I meet them and they're not ready.
Because like...
I don't know when I'll need a car.
Like...
I don't know when I need to drive somewhere.
It feels like it's a lot more expensive than Uber.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Broco, thank you for the gifted ship.
I don't trust bikes.
Unless you live in Europe, I don't...
I'm sorry.
But like...
As long as you live...
The worst part of living in Canada...
And I guess America...
I think it's a thing in America too.
Is that everything is so fucking far.
Even when you're in the city.
Nothing is close by.
Like, everything is like...
A fucking 15 minute walk to anywhere.
Like, you gotta...
You gotta live in a place...
Like, even when you live in a fucking city in Canada.
Like, not...
True, not in New York City.
But like...
Like...
Yeah, we're the second biggest...
Country in the world.
But like...
I'm pretty sure 70% of Canada...
Is just ice.
It's just...
The land.
Like, there's nothing there.
It's literally just the land.
Only 70%...
It's just...
Yeah, it's just...
It's just a little wild back here.
If it's not ice, it's forests and lakes.
Yeah, and then like...
The last like...
Like, the last 30% is the actual...
The actual like...
Place you can live in.
Well, I tried in that case.
I do, I have a...
I have a license.
I just haven't driven a car in a long time.
I don't trust myself.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
By the way, I recently found out...
I have a dog park in my building.
Yeah, I was trying to find out.
Cause I was like...
I was like...
I was like, do I have a...
Cause like, I was trying to figure out like...
Like, dance studios to rent.
And then like...
I was looking up like...
The amenities in my building.
And I didn't know.
I've been living here for so long.
Like, we have a gym and stuff.
And like a pool.
But like, I didn't realize we have a fucking dog park.
Cause I was trying to look for like...
I was like, oh, do we have like a dance room?
So I was looking up the map.
And then I see on the map.
It's like, here's the building's dog park.
And I was like, what?
So I went there like...
Like, it's really tiny.
It's like a really tiny little place for like dogs.
And...
And there's actual like...
You know like those like dog parkour stuff?
Like, you know, when you're doing dog shows and stuff.
And then they have those like ramps and everything.
And there's hoops to jump through.
They had that shit.
I mean like, dad can't fucking jump through those hoops.
It's like really tall.
But they had that.
It's a tiny one.
But like, you can like...
They even have like little dog poop bags that you can just use to pick up.
And like, it's crazy.
Like, how would that jump for me?
Yeah.
And I was just like, I have a dog park?
And I was like, holy shit.
Anyway.
That's great.
And Nick let's me...
It's like...
Now I'm like...
So that's where they...
Sometimes I was like...
Why do they...
Sometimes I see people with their dogs and they stop off at a particular floor.
And I'm like, wait.
Why are they stopping off at that floor?
That's where the gym is.
Like...
I didn't realize there was a dog park getting in there.
Like, I was like...
Why did they go and fucking take their dog to the gym?
I would always be so confused.
Because I'd be like, why did they stop on this floor?
And I'm like, oh, now.
Now that's why.
I fucking was going...
I was walking my dog like a fucking caveman outside.
Like...
I'm like, I can't believe I had to take my dog outside.
Like the peasants.
I could have...
I can't believe...
Like the commoners outside.
Like...
I could have been...
I could have been walking in the fancy dog park.
I'm about these commoners where their buildings don't have dog parks.
Like a fucking casual.
Oh, what was funny was that...
There were like other owners there.
With their dogs.
And then like...
And then their dogs were like super social.
And then my dog was like anti-social.
I mean, he tried.
He tried.
But then they were like...
Way too social.
They were like...
And so...
So he didn't like that.
Because he didn't like how active they are.
So like...
He walked...
Because he walked up to the owners.
And like started barking at them.
And was like...
Was like...
Teach them...
Just like...
Control your dogs.
He literally like...
Walked up to the owners.
Like...
There were like three dogs.
At the park.
At the...
You know, the building.
Dog park.
And he like walked up to like...
The owners.
And was like...
Teach...
Teach them to control themselves.
He just like...
I was like...
Please.
Don't do that.
What is wrong with him?
Because he didn't like how...
Because they kept like bothering him.
And he didn't like that.
He was like...
Look.
I tolerate your presence.
He didn't like how they were like...
Want him to like...
He didn't like...
He didn't like that.
He like...
They want him to be more...
Social.
Like the other dogs.
They were like...
Why don't you play with us?
And then he was like...
He was like...
Get away from...
Look.
I'm tolerating you right now.
And then they wouldn't stop bothering him.
They wouldn't stop bothering him.
So he just walked up to the owners.
And just started barking at them.
Because he got mad.
He got so annoyed.
I'm like...
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Anyway.
So there's that.
What else is there?
I'm looking at...
Let's see.
I'm looking at like...
My list of stuff I want to talk about.
Oh yeah.
You know what was funny?
I got my hair done.
And then they were like...
Oh yeah.
Make sure you don't...
Like, you don't wash your hair for two days for the dye to set in.
I was like...
Sweet.
And then I went outside and it was raining.
I'm like...
Not sweet.
I was like...
Okay.
I had a raincoat on, but still.
I was just like...
It wasn't raining before.
The sun was out!
I took my chance.
I was like...
The sun's out.
It's a good day.
What could go wrong?
And then three hours later, it started raining.
I had a raincoat on, but like, you know.
And then when I almost got home, it stopped raining.
It was like...
When I was like five minutes from home, the clouds were gone.
And I'm like...
Bro.
I could've waited at the salon if I knew that the clouds were gonna stop.
If the rain was gonna stop.
That was my life.
That was targeted right there.
That was targeted harassment.
Right there.
If I could, I would report the sky to HR.
If I could.
Alright, back to...
I'll read five more superchats.
I talked a lot today.
Thank you, superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, the man with one eye is already closing his eyes to aim.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Wait, but what about depth perception?
You lose your depth perception.
I mean, to be fair, I have two eyes and I still don't have depth perception.
But that's different.
That's different.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Memento, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Welcome to the SBMM hell.
That is modern cod.
It only gets worse from here.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh yeah!
Hardcore Minecraft with Mint on the six.
On the six.
And we're not gonna stop stream until we beat hardcore Minecraft.
We waited.
The reason why it took so long to get this collab going is that we waited because we were waiting for Mint to debut her new model.
So, that's why.
Because we thought it'd be better.
Because, you know, shiny.
So, that's why.
That's why, like, we haven't said anything about it for a while.
But next week.
Next week, we're gonna have it on the six, I believe.
I think so, yeah.
We were, like, talking about it yesterday.
What else?
Cat!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
That's it.
You're down, kiddo.
The boys are waiting for us.
Oh yeah.
I can't wait for you guys to see what I cooked for Halloween.
I know her stream starts at four.
So, like, that's why I scheduled mine at six.
I don't know if it'll be done by then.
But, like, you know, let's you guys have time to enjoy her new model debut.
Before you hop over to my stream.
Or, like, don't.
Or don't and just watch the VOD.
When her stream's over.
Delta, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
For your knife-buying fun.
Doki, get some good knives, including a bread knife.
My oshi needs to adopt better.
I'm getting
better at being an adult now.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Soma, thank you for the superchat.
Doki wore a $300 haircut.
Bro, he didn't even cut that...
I mean, I think he did layers or something.
Cause, like, um...
Cause I didn't know.
I don't really care that much.
I don't know.
Like, I don't care too...
I know, like, hair is important.
But, like, it's so annoying.
Cause, like, oh my god.
When he was, like, trying...
I was like, yeah, I need you to thin my hair.
Because, like, I have a lot of hair.
So, um, it's so annoying.
Cause, like, cause he was, like...
He was dyeing my hair.
And then, and then, like...
He used up the entire dye.
And he was like, wait.
Oh my god, you have so much hair.
Like...
Cause, like, he had to make a second batch.
Cause there was too much.
It's just...
He, like...
He got, like, his, you know, his, like...
Bag of dye.
And then, he was like...
He finished the entire...
He finished the entire bowl.
And then, there was still, like, 40% left to do.
And, um...
And, like, I told you.
Like, I was like, yeah, I told you.
Like, I need you...
I need you to thin it out.
Like...
Um...
Like, it's a bowl of dye.
And, um...
Every time, like, it's just so annoying.
Cause it's actually, like, really heavy.
And, like, my hair grows back so fast, too.
So, it's so annoying.
And, like, usually, I just...
I just, like, trim it.
Like, um...
I trim it.
And then, I sell $300.
Like, I sell $300.
It's cause of the dye.
The dye was the fucking issue.
Like, it's, like...
I didn't even realize.
There's, like...
Oh, my God.
I swear.
Cutting hair has, like, evolved so much.
Cause now, you have ear guards, too.
They put, like, these little...
Like, things on your ears.
They guard your ears.
So, like, the dye won't, like, touch your ears and everything.
And I'm, like, wow.
I can't believe I didn't have that.
Like, as a...
As a child.
Cause, like...
Yeah, children ears are not that good, I guess.
Like, children ears aren't that important.
Cause I swear, I never had these fucking ear guards before.
The ear shield.
Like, that's when you know I'm in a fancy place.
Let me try going full white here.
That doesn't work!
It's not, like, my head.
It's, like, full white hair.
Um...
It's not even full, uh...
White hair.
It's, like...
Um...
It's, like, strands of it.
Like, it's not even full.
It's, like, some...
So, like, it's not even together.
That's the worst part.
It's not, like, they grow together.
It's, like...
It's, like, they grow in some places.
Like...
It's, like...
It's, like, random spray.
Like, you know, like...
You know, when you're spraying a AK-47 and it's a random spray on the fucking...
Sorry, I'm...
Like, for you gamers who don't understand...
For...
For you...
For you gamers who don't understand about, like, hair.
So, it's, like, when you get an AK-47, you spray a lot and it's, like, a random spray.
And...
That's, like...
That's, like, my hair.
It doesn't...
It doesn't go in, like...
Um...
One area.
Like, one tiny area.
It's, like, somehow there'd be, like, a white hair in there and a white hair there.
And it's, like...
It's not even, like, too little that you can...
And, like, you know...
I have dark hair, so, like, it pops out, too.
Can you explain it in Apex terms?
Yeah!
Yeah, I can explain it in Apex terms.
So, like, you know when you get a Peacekeeper and, like, you know...
Sometimes you hit, like, tens instead of a hundred.
So, because of the spread.
So, like, instead of hitting a hundred, you know, all the white hair at the hundred...
It's, like, at a ten, because, like...
Like, 90% of that goes to a different area.
So...
Understandable.
Yeah, the shot pattern.
Oh, I get it now.
I understand.
Now that you explained it in Apex terms.
Like...
So, yeah, that's basically how it works.
But it's so fucking annoying.
But, yeah, I haven't...
Like I said, I haven't dyed my hair in, like, a year and a half.
Because, you know, I never felt like I needed to.
And, like, I was really busy and everything.
But now it's like, you know what?
I'm gonna treat myself.
Now, like, I don't like looking at the gray hair.
Like, I was like...
I was at a point, I was like, I don't like looking at the gray hair anymore.
I was like, I look like a fucking...
Oh, my God, I look like a mess.
Like, you know, go outside and be like, what's wrong with her?
You know?
Like, I could tell...
Like, now I could tell.
It's just like, you know...
Like, it's like I don't have things together.
Like, all together.
So, I was like, oh, I should, like...
I know.
I should at least look like I have something together.
Like, my life's not a mess right now.
So, it's weird because, like...
Back then, I don't go outside a lot.
But now I do.
So, like, I go outside a lot now.
For, like, adult stuff.
So...
So, like...
So, like, now that I go outside more, I was like, oh, man, no.
Now I can actually be judged.
So...
Guys, I'm not...
Guys, it's not because, like, I'm getting old.
I told you.
I had gray hair since I was, like, four.
I had gray hair since I was four because I'm like...
I don't produce enough melanin in my hair.
So, like...
So, I've had gray hair since four.
It's just...
For a year and a half, I just didn't care.
Because I was like, I don't need to go outside.
But now I do.
So, now I'm like, fuck, I actually do.
I do have to dye my hair.
Anyway, guys.
I'm Gala here.
I had a great time talking with all you guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stand for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Also, nominate me at the streamer awards.
I don't know about getting a nomination.
But, you know, it's worth a shot.
I don't know.
It'd be cool if I do get nominated.
I don't expect to win.
I just thought it'd be cool if I get nominated.
And that's really all I want.
So, yeah.
Just go to the link.
Go to the link.
And then just write, like, best VTuber.
I don't even remember what the category is.
Something VTuber.
Just do control F, VTuber, write Doki Bird.
That's it.
I really appreciate it.
I know it's a popular vote to get nominated.
So, yeah.
So, it's mostly just, like, whoever...
It's like those, like...
What is it called?
It's like those streamer awards.
You remember those streamer awards?
Where it's literally, like, people just rally their fans to, like, submit.
Nominate themselves, like, every day or something.
Like, I don't do that.
But, like, I just figured, like, just put it up for a bit.
And then...
And, yeah.
I just thought it'd be cool if I get nominated.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody, say, hi, J-Paw.
Check him around to get that blood flowing.
Say it for me.
Head to bed.
I think I already said that before, but I'm going to say it again.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.